Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is, therestishistory.com. No Frills delivers. Get groceries delivered to your door from No Frills with PC Express. Shop online and get $15 in PC Optimum Points on your first five orders. Shop now at nofrills.ca. I joined the flying column in 1916 in Cork with Sean Mylan in Tipperary with Dan Breen, arrested by free-staters and sentenced for to die.
感谢收听《The Rest is History》。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。再次提醒，网址是 therestishistory.com。No Frills 绝不含糊。通过 PC Express，让 No Frills 将杂货直接送到您的门前。在线购物并在前五笔订单中获得 15 加元的 PC Optimum 积分。立即访问 nofrills.ca 选购。我于 1916 年在科克加入“飞动纵队”，与肖恩·迈伦并肩作战；在蒂珀雷里与丹·布林并肩作战，后被自由邦成员逮捕并被判处死刑。
Farewell to Tipperary, said the Galtie Mountain boy. We went across the valleys and oared the hilltops green, where we met with Dinny Lacey, Sean Hogan and Dan Breen. Sean Mullen and his gallant men, they kept the flag flying high. And farewell to Tipperary, said the Galtie Mountain boy. I bid farewell to Aul Clonmel, I nevermore shall see, and to the Galtie Mountains that oft-time sheltered me. Those who fought for liberty and died without a sigh, may their cause not be forgotten, said the Galtie Mountain Boy.
再见，蒂珀雷里，加尔蒂山的小伙子这样说道。我们穿过山谷，划过翠绿的山巅，在那里我们遇到了迪尼·莱西、肖恩·霍根和丹·布林。肖恩·穆伦和他英勇的部下们，让旗帜高高飘扬。再见，蒂珀雷里，加尔蒂山的小伙子这样说道。我向老克隆梅尔告别，此生再难相见，也向曾多次庇护我的加尔蒂山告别。那些为自由而战、毫无遗憾地离去的人们，愿他们的事业不被遗忘，加尔蒂山的小伙子这样说道。
So that was The Galtie Mountain Boy, written by Patsy O'Halloran and Christie Moore, and delivered quite beautifully by a man we will be introducing in a few moments. And it's the story of a teenage volunteer who joins the Irish Republican cause in 1916. He fights the British in the Irish Republican cause in 1916. He fights the British in the Irish War of Independence, but he's sentenced to death by his own former comrades,
这首歌曲就是《加尔蒂山的小伙子》，由帕特西·奥哈洛兰和克里斯蒂·摩尔创作，由一位我们稍后将向大家介绍的男士深情演绎。它讲述了一个十几岁的志愿者的故事，他在 1916 年加入了爱尔兰共和派的事业。他为了爱尔兰共和派的事业在 1916 年与英国人战斗。他参加了爱尔兰独立战争，却被自己昔日的战友判处死刑，
the Free Staters in the Irish Civil War. And Tom, for me, that ticks every Irish ballad box. There's a lot of geography. There's a lot of stuff about freedom and flags. There are random names of folk heroes that mean a lot to Irish listeners but perhaps not to British ones and dare I say a general air of is Morkishness the right word? There speaks the voice of Dublin Castle. Yeah exactly. Are you a fan of an Irish ballad? I love an Irish ballad and I especially love it because it's very convenient for our purposes because two of the men mentioned in that ballad, Sean Hogan and Dan Breen, will feature in the dramatic story of the ambush at Solohead Beg, which is the first engagement of the Irish War of Independence, and this is going to be the theme of our episode today.
也就是爱尔兰内战中的自由邦人。汤姆，对我和来说，这完全契合了所有爱尔兰民谣的经典要素。里面有大量的地理名称。有很多关于自由和旗帜的内容。还有一些对爱尔兰听众意义重大、但对英国听众可能毫无意义的民间英雄的随机名字，而且我敢说，还有一种普遍的……“感伤”是合适的词吗？这话听起来就像都柏林城堡传出的声音。没错。你是个爱尔兰民谣迷吗？我很喜欢爱尔兰民谣，我尤其喜欢它，因为它对我们的节目大有帮助，因为民谣中提到的两个人，肖恩·霍根和丹·布林，将出现在索洛黑德贝格伏击这一戏剧性故事中，这是爱尔兰独立战争的第一次交火，这也将成为我们今天节目的主题。
And just to give people a spoiler alert, some of the characters mentioned, including the two that I've just named, were a bit less romantic, I think, than the song suggests. But for now, let's just remind everyone where we are because we are in Dublin. We are in the Royal Irish Academy, so that's the RIA, and we might be using the same letters in a different form later on in this story because we are telling the story
顺便给听众们一个剧透，提到的某些人物，包括我刚才点名那两位，其实没有歌曲里描绘的那般浪漫。但现在，让我们先提醒大家我们身在何处，因为我们在都柏林。我们在皇家爱尔兰学院，也就是 RIA，在这场故事的后续部分，我们可能会以不同的形式使用这几个字母，因为我们要讲述的是
of the Irish revolutionary struggle at the end of the First World War and Dominic, we ended last time in December 1918. We tracked how over the two years since the Easter Rising in 1916, they've been growing radicalisation. Sinn Fein had won a landslide majority in Ireland in the general election, and they had won this massive majority in Ireland in the general election and they had won this massive majority in Ireland on a ticket of building an independent Irish Republic and they had said that they would do that by whatever means were required. Now much as I love listening to you Tom I think we should have an Irish voice so we are joined once again by Irish National Treasurer, Professor at University College Dublin, friend of the show, a man described by a listener to the last Irish series we did as a pound shot bono.
第一次世界大战结束时爱尔兰革命斗争的故事。多米尼克，上次节目我们讲到了 1918 年 12 月。我们回顾了自 1916 年复活节起义以来的两年里，激进主义是如何不断高涨的。新芬党在爱尔兰的大选中赢得了压倒性多数，他们在爱尔兰大选中赢得了这压倒性的多数，他们凭借建立一个独立的爱尔兰共和国的政治纲领，在爱尔兰赢得了这压倒性的多数，并且他们曾表示将不惜一切代价实现这一目标。虽然我很喜欢听你讲，汤姆，但我觉得我们应该听听爱尔兰本土的声音，所以我们再次迎来了爱尔兰国家财务主管、都柏林大学学院教授、节目老朋友保罗·鲁斯教授，一位被我们上次做的爱尔兰系列节目的听众形容为“廉价版博诺”的男士。
It is Professor Paul Rouse. Well, Paul, to be fair, you didn't sing it. So yeah. Oh yeah. I think there would be family members warned me in advance that singing would not be a wise thing to do. The pound shot bono line was seized on. I'm blessed with friends who
这就是保罗·鲁斯教授。好吧，保罗，平心而论，你当时可没唱歌。所以，是的。哦，是的。我想有家人提前警告过我，唱歌可不是什么明智之举。“廉价版博诺”这句话一下子就被抓住了。我有一群……
don't really worry about the difference between insult and compliment, but they seized on the insult after the last time I appeared. Okay. So come on then Bono. We're in, we ended last time in December of 1918 with the election and Sinn Fein have won, but they're not going to take their seats in the House of Commons and their pledge to an Irish Republic. So let's move to January 1919 and there's one day in particular which looms so large, it's the 21st of January because two things happen, two extraordinary events happen on the same day. Each of them in their own right would be remarkable. The fact that they happened on the same day makes it a truly singular day in Irish history. They weren't planned to happen on the same day as you will see, but the first thing is
他们根本不在乎侮辱和赞美有什么区别的朋友，但在我上次出场后，他们偏偏揪住了这个侮辱不放。好吧。那来吧，博诺。我们回到正题，上次节目我们在 1918 年 12 月的大选结束时结束，新芬党赢了，但他们不会去下议院占领席位，而是要兑现对爱尔兰共和国的誓言。所以让我们进入 1919 年 1 月，有一个日子尤为重要，那就是 1 月 21 日，因为有两件大事、两件非同寻常的事件在同一天发生了。每一件单独拿出来看都堪称非凡。而它们恰好发生在同一天，这使这一天在爱尔兰历史上具有真正无与伦比的意义。正如你将看到的，它们并不是计划在同一天发生的，但第一件事是
a meeting in the Mansion House right next door to us here at the Academy as the Mansion House is the official residence of the city mayor. And what happened in that room is a remarkable moment in the Irish national story. 27 of the 73 Sinn Fein MPs who had been elected to the House of Commons, all of them had said they weren't going to take their seats, but they convened in the mansion house and established what was called Dáil Éireann, the Irish parliament. It should be said that one of those who was not able to be present was Countess Markiewicz, who was then in Holloway jail. And she was the first female to be elected as a member of parliament in the House of Commons, although, of course, she did not take her seat.
在宅邸官邸举行的一场会议，该官邸就在我们学院的隔壁，宅邸官邸是市长的官邸。那个房间里发生的事情是爱尔兰民族历史上意义非凡的时刻。在当选进入下议院的 73 名新芬党议员中，有 27 人——他们所有人都曾表示不会去议会占领席位——在宅邸官邸集会，成立了所谓的“爱尔兰议会”（Dáil Éireann）。必须说明的是，当时无法出席的人之一是马凯维奇伯爵夫人，她当时被关在霍洛威监狱。她是第一位当选下议院议员的女性，尽管她当然没有去占领席位。
So that's another count. Her husband is a Polish count, isn't he? Or was he? Yes. She's a very glamorous figure. She's a very glamorous figure who was also, by the way, is mischaracterized, I think, a lot by history. She's one of those women who was also, by the way, is mischaracterized, I think, a lot by history. She's one of those women who was central to the Irish Revolution over the years, but she really labored.
所以这是另一位伯爵。她的丈夫是一位波兰伯爵，对吧？曾经是吗？是的。她是一个极具魅力的人物。她是一个极具魅力的人物，顺便说一句，我认为她经常被历史误解。她就是那种女性……顺便说一句，我认为她经常被历史误解。她就是那种女性，多年来一直是爱尔兰革命的核心人物，但她确实付出了艰辛的努力。
She was not somebody who was a leader who frittered around the margins. She did the dirty, hard, organizational work who anyone who's ever run any organization knows it's hard to do this. And she is one of the group of women who was fundamental to this whole story. And ultimately she will give away all her inherited wealth and die a poor woman. She died a poor woman, she died very young, she died in ill health but deserves to be remembered as a significant historical figure. Now this meeting in the mansion house of these elected members, 27 of them, was largely ceremonial in nature, but it saw the realisation of four foundational documents. The first is the Constitution of Dáil Éireann, as the Irish Parliament was called. And this was a kind of a short, but
她不是那种在边缘地带无所事事的领导者。她做的是那些脏累的、组织性的工作，任何运营过任何组织的人都知道这有多难。她是推动整个故事走向的核心女性群体之一。最终，她放弃了自己继承的所有财富，以一个穷人的身份去世。她死时很贫困，英年早逝，在病痛中离世，但她理应作为一位重要的历史人物被人们铭记。现在，这些当选议员（其中27人）在官邸举行的这次会议，本质上主要是礼仪性的，但它实现了四个奠基性文件。第一个是爱尔兰议会（即爱尔兰议会的名称）宪法。这是一个简短的，但
it was the basic underpinning of the state. And it's really interesting, but the cabinet that was formed had five departments, financial affairs, home affairs, foreign affairs, the presidents and defence and it was based on the model of the British cabinet system. But that kind of makes sense because that's the model they're familiar with I guess. Entirely and they get they want people to sway from one to the other to pretend that the other doesn't exist and to come to us. The second is a declaration of independence which rejects 700 years of occupation because the clock was still ticking at that stage and it only got to just over 700 and established an Irish Republic. And that's a massive
它是国家的基本基石。这真的很有趣，新芬党组建的内阁设有五个部门：财政事务、内政、外交、总统和国防，它是仿照英国内阁制建立的。这其实也说得通，因为我想这是他们熟悉的模式。完全如此，他们希望人们从一个部门转向另一个部门，假装另一个部门不存在，然后来找我们。第二个是《独立宣言》，它拒绝了长达 700 年的占领，因为当时时间仍在流逝，而且刚好刚超过 700 年，并建立了一个爱尔兰共和国。这是一个极其重大
thing. It established an Irish Republic. It said we're going to pretend that your state does not exist and we are going to establish our own. We're going to craft it on. And this is what Griffith wanted to happen in the early 1900s. That's what he argued for. So it's kind of creating the Republic by sheer force of will almost. Yeah, making it real, making a practical thing, not just an aspirational thing or not just words, but actually putting it in place. It had a Declaration of Independence, as I say, which was there.
的事件。它建立了一个爱尔兰共和国。它宣称：我们要假装你们的国家不存在，我们要建立我们自己的国家。我们要以此为蓝本。这就是格里菲斯在 20 世纪初想要实现的目标。这也是他当时所力争的。所以这几乎纯粹是靠坚定的意志力来创建共和国。是的，把它变成现实，创造一个切实存在的东西，而不仅仅是一个愿景或几句空洞的口号，而是真正地将其实施。正如我所说，它有一份《独立宣言》，这都是现成的。
But there was also a message to the free nations of the world. And that was all about the Paris Peace Conference and the kind of channel that would roll Wilson 14 points about self-determination and anti-imperialism. And of course, the choice of French, the fact that that was published and spoken in English, Irish and French tells you the audience that that was aimed at. And the final thing is a democratic program, which is a kind of a very socially and economically leftist program, certainly influenced by socialism and with that kind of idea of what was happening
但同时它也向世界自由国家发出了一个信息。这完全是关于巴黎和平会议的，以及类似于威尔逊关于民族自决和反帝国主义的十四点和平原则的渠道。当然，它以英语、爱尔兰语和法语三种语言出版并发表，这一事实告诉你它的目标受众是谁。最后一项是民主纲领，这是一个在社会和经济上非常左翼的纲领，无疑受到了社会主义的影响，并带有当时
in Russia in the background. It was pretty radical and it made some people in the Dáil pretty uncomfortable, not least of whom was Kevin O'Higgins, a Labour minister in government who described it as largely poetry. And to end due course Countess Markievicz will become the Minister of Labour, won't she? And the second woman to become a European minister. Yes and the fact that it's seen as, the fact that it's a shadow government is sometimes used to dismiss that fact but again I think it's important but this was ultimately in short a revolutionary assembly. And then the amazing thing is that on the same day in Tipperary I think it is there is an event that is often seen as the first armed clash of the war and as you said it's not meant to be
俄国发生的事情的背景烙印。它相当激进，这让议会里的一些人感到很不舒服，其中就包括政府劳动大臣凯文·奥希金斯，他将其形容为“大段的诗歌”。在适当的时候，马凯维奇伯爵夫人将成为劳工部部长，不是吗？并且是第二位成为欧洲内阁部长的女性。是的，它被视为影子政府，有时人们用这一点来贬低其事实上的意义，但我再次认为这很重要，总之，这本质上是一个革命性的议会。然后神奇的事情发生了，在同一天的蒂珀雷里，我认为，发生了一起通常被视为战争第一次武装冲突的事件，正如你所说，这并非刻意安排，
it's not it's a coincidence it's not designed that way so tell us what happens at Sallowheadbeg and where it matters. So Tipperary is a county in the centre of Ireland and there is a town called Tipperary Town right in the heart of that county. On a cold damp morning in January 1919, the 21st of January, James MacDonald and Patrick O'Connell, who were two local policemen, were leading a horse and cart which were being driven by Patrick Flynn and Edward Godfrey. They were bringing gelignite from Tipperary town out to a quarry at Solahead Beg to blow stones for the construction work that was happening around the place. Tipperary was a famously rebellious county. famously rebellious county.
这不是故意的，这纯属巧合，并不是这样设计的。所以给我们讲讲索洛黑德贝格发生了什么，以及它为什么重要。蒂珀雷里是爱尔兰中部的一个郡，在这个郡的正中心有一个叫蒂珀雷里镇的小镇。在 1919 年 1 月一个寒冷潮湿的早晨，即 1 月 21 日，两名当地警察詹姆斯·麦克唐纳和帕特里克·奥康奈尔正押送着一辆由帕特里克·弗林和爱德华·戈弗雷驾驶的马车。他们正把炸药从蒂珀雷里镇运送到索洛黑德贝格的一座采石场，用来爆破碎石，以进行各地的建设工作。蒂珀雷里是一个出了名的反叛郡。一个出了名的反叛郡。
Tipperary had been the home of the 1867 rebellion and everything to do with Irish nationalism had a Tipperary strain to it, but Tipperary had not risen in 1916. And that caused deep pain to people such as Sean Tracy in particular, but also Dan Breen, Seamus Robinson and Sean Hogan. And they're among a group of eight volunteers, this newly militarizing force who are desperate for action because they believe that unless somebody is killed there is no war of independence beginning. They wish to kill somebody, they wish to start a war, they wish to shoot and they use the opportunity of this Jellig Knight being moved to a quarry because they think they can get
蒂珀雷里是 1867 年起义的发源地，所有与爱尔兰民族主义有关的事物都有着蒂珀雷里的印记，但蒂珀雷里并没有在 1916 年起义。这给肖恩·特雷西特别是丹·布林、谢默斯·罗宾逊和肖恩·霍根等人带来了深深的痛楚。他们是八名渴望行动的志愿者之一，这支新近军事化的力量迫切渴望战斗，因为他们相信，除非有人被杀，否则独立战争就不会真正爆发。他们渴望杀人，渴望挑起战争，渴望开枪，他们利用运送炸药去采石场的机会，因为他们认为可以从押送的警察那里
arms off whatever police are bringing because the Irish police were armed in the countryside not in Dublin City but armed in the countryside take their arms take the Jellignite and you have both bomb making potential and you have guns and ammunition so the cart is going out of country lane there was an attempt to slow it down with a bicycle someone stopping with a puncture and fixing a puncture it slows down and Tracy Robinson Hogan and Breen come out and Tracy at least shoots one of them and it's not, they had really poor arms in what they were doing but Tracy is said to have danced and kissed his rifle after he shot one of the policemen who was left lying on the ground. Sean Hogan took off
夺取武器——因为乡村里的爱尔兰警察是有武装的，都柏林市内的没有，但乡村里的警察有武装——夺取他们的武器，夺取炸药，这样你们既有了制造炸弹的潜力，又有了枪支弹药。所以马车正沿着乡村小路驶去，有人试图用一辆自行车放慢它的速度，某人假装爆胎并在那里修车，车速慢了下来，特雷西、罗宾逊、霍根和布林从一旁冲了出来，特雷西至少向其中一人开了枪。而且，他们当时使用的武器真的很差劲，但据说特雷西在向其中一名倒在地上的警察开枪后，兴奋得又跳舞又亲吻自己的步枪。肖恩·霍根带着
with the horse and cart with the gelignite and they dispersed across the countryside. These are the first shots in the Irish War of Independence. And to be clear, the two policemen who are shot, so MacDonald and O'Connell, they are Irish Catholic policemen. They're not British. They are they're part of a large number of Irish Catholic policemen who are working for the state at that point. Yes. Patrick O'Connell was 30 years of age from Cork, lived locally, known locally, most likely known to the people who killed him. James MacDonald was from Bellmullet in County Mayo.
装有炸药的马车逃走了，他们四散逃入乡村。这是爱尔兰独立战争的第一枪。需要明确的是，中枪的两名警察，即麦克唐纳和奥康奈尔，是爱尔兰天主教警察。他们不是英国人。他们是当时为国家效力的众多爱尔兰天主教警察的一部分。是的，帕特里克·奥康奈尔 30 岁，来自科克，当地人，在当地生活，当地人都认识他，极有可能杀他的人也认识他。詹姆斯·麦克唐纳来自梅奥郡的贝利莫利特。
He was in his 50s, but he was a widower with five youngest children and an Irish speaker. Is there a sense this is a terrible thing? This is a terrible tragedy? Oh, there's an outcry against it. Right. The idea that Breen and Tracy and Robinson and Hogan would somehow be celebrated in the local area for what they did is not correct. There was a revulsion locally about what had happened. The view locally was that these were well-liked policemen who were in the area and Breen and Tracy had to go on the run.
他五十多岁了，是一个丧偶的父亲，抚养着五个年幼的孩子，还会说爱尔兰语。人们当时觉得这是一件可怕的事情吗？这是一场可怕的悲剧吗？哦，社会各界对此群情激愤。没错。布林、特雷西、罗宾逊和霍根因为他们的所作所为而在当地受到赞颂，这种想法是不正确的。当地对发生的事情感到一种极度的反感。当地的看法是，这些都是当地广受喜爱的警察，布林和特雷西不得不走上逃亡之路。
And there's outrage in the papers, outrage from the pulpit. And even people in Dublin, people who are involved in the movement, they don't like this. Right. Because, Paul, you say that the men who do this want it to be a declaration of war, but reading about it and then the events that follow, it actually reminds me of the Wild West. It's like the kind of, it's the subject of a spaghetti western or something like that. And it becomes even more so, doesn't it, because in due course that the four men who have done the attack disperse, they go into hiding, they're on the run, being hunted down by lawmen, and then one of them gets captured and he gets put on a train
报纸上充斥着愤怒的声讨，布道坛上也传出了愤怒的谴责。甚至连都柏林的人们，那些参与这场运动的人，也不喜欢这样。没错。因为，保罗，你刚才说实施这一切的人希望这就是宣战，但通过阅读相关资料以及随后的事件，这实际上让我想起了美国西部荒野。这就像是那种……这是一部意大利式西部片或者类似题材的主题。而且情况更是如此，对吧？因为随后这四名发动袭击的男子四散逃窜，他们开始隐蔽逃亡，被执法人员追捕，接着其中一人被捕，他被押上火车
to be taken off to trial and presumably ultimately to be hanged and the other three stage a hold up. They get on the train, there's a massive shoot out on the train and they manage to get Hogan free. They're all got blood spurting out of their arms and their chests and things and then they take him off and they get a butcher's cleaver to hack through the handcuffs. And you could absolutely imagine Clint Eastwood starring in a film of this story. And it is a guerrilla war.
准备送往审判，并可能最终被绞死，而其余三人则策划了一场拦截营救。他们上了火车，在火车上发生了激烈的枪战，他们成功把霍根救了出来。他们所有人的手臂和胸膛上都血流如注，然后他们把他带下车，找来一把屠夫的切肉刀砍断手铐。你绝对可以想象克林特·伊斯特伍德主演这样一个故事的电影。这是一场游击战。
The Set Piece War of 1916 is done. They know, they've learned they're not going back into a building. This is a hedge war and it's an urban streets war. Now, in the mythology of the Irish Revolution, it's that all of this fighting happened in country lanes and on the sides of mountains and people melted off into the countryside and lived on the land and were fed by people and that. And that did happen. But it was also an urban guerrilla war as well, which spread to the cities.
1916 年的那种阵地战已经结束了。他们知道，他们吸取了教训，不会再固守在一栋建筑里了。这是一场在树篱间进行的战争，也是一场城市街道战。现在，在爱尔兰革命的神话中，所有的这些战斗都发生在乡间小路和山坡上，人们隐匿到乡村中，靠土地维生，由当地民众提供食物。这确实发生过。但它同时也是一场城市游击战，并蔓延到了各大城市。
But not yet. 1919, in terms of the War of Independence is really quiet. But Breen and Tracy are at the heart of it and they're on the run immediately. And just on those men, we mentioned, Tom said, you know, they're maybe not as romantic as the ballad makes them. I mean, these are quite, these are hard men. These are men who like a fight. So Dan Breen was a hard, violent man who was utterly unrepentant about killing
但当时还没有。1919 年，就独立战争而言，局势其实相当平静。但布林和特雷西身处其中，他们立刻踏上了逃亡之路。说到这些人，正如汤姆所说，他们可能并不像民谣中描绘的那般浪漫。我的意思是，这些人相当……他们是硬汉。这些人是喜欢战斗的硬汉。所以，丹·布林是一个强悍、好斗且对自己杀害
people. And you can see that in the interviews that were recorded with him, for example, in the 1960s, and it was glorified in his book, My Fight for Irish Freedom. There was a wanted poster for Breen. So he is very well dressed. Yeah. And it was a reward of one thousand pounds for anyone who hands him in. But he's described on the wanted poster as a picture of him, kind of in, you know, relatively well dressed, but the picture of him is describing him as having a sulky
人的行为毫无悔意的硬汉。你可以从 20 世纪 60 年代为他录制的采访中看到这一点，他的书《我为爱尔兰自由而战》也将其美化了。当时有一张针对布林的通缉令。他穿着十分体面。是的。对提供线索抓捕他的人悬赏一千英镑。但通缉令上对他的描述附有一张照片，照片里的他穿着相对得体，但通缉令上的照片将他描述为有着一副闷闷不乐的
bulldog appearance and looking like a blacksmith on his way home from work. It's kind of remarkable that people put that on the poster. Paul, I guess see why to the British authorities, this does seem a law and order issue rather than the declaration of a war, right? And the fact that it was so slow to get going, if you look at what happened, the slow incremental rise in violence, particularly in the first half of 1919, it got a little bit quicker later in 1919. But what it really was, was assaults. They were looking, they didn't have rifles, they didn't have guns, they didn't have ammunition,
斗牛犬般的外表，看起来像一个下班回家的铁匠。人们竟然把这种描述印在通缉令上，真是挺不可思议的。保罗，我大概能理解为什么对英国当局来说，这更像是一个法律与秩序的问题，而不是宣战，对吧？而且事实是，这场运动的发展如此缓慢，如果你看看发生的事情，暴力事件呈缓慢递增的趋势，特别是在 1919 年上半年，1919 年下半年情况稍微加快了一些。但它真正表现出来的其实是袭击。他们在搜寻——他们没有步枪，没有枪支，没有弹药，
they didn't have much bomb making equipment. So what you have are the volunteers raiding for arms, raiding houses for arms, raiding police stations for arms, trying to find guns wherever they can get them, organising boycotts, assaulting the police and loyalists and resisting arrest. So for the first suede of the Irish war of independence, the level of violence is really small scale. So in 1919, a lot of the stories about boycotts, isn't it? So you mentioned the importance of boycotts and it's boycotts, particularly of people who are like these policemen, people who are in the Royal Irish Constabulary and it's about not selling them, you wouldn't
他们也没有多少制造炸弹的设备。所以你看到的是志愿者们突袭搜寻武器，突袭民宅搜寻武器，突袭警察局搜寻武器，千方百计地寻找枪支，组织抵制活动，袭击警察和效忠派，并抗拒逮捕。因此，在爱尔兰独立战争的大部分时间里，暴力活动的规模其实非常小。所以到了 1919 年，许多故事都与抵制有关，对吧？所以你提到了抵制的重要性，这其中包括抵制那些像这些警察一样的人，那些在皇家爱尔兰警察局供职的人，其核心就是不把东西卖给他们，你不会
sell them milk, you wouldn't sell them eggs, you would basically, in England we would use the expression, you'd send them to Coventry, you'd basically sort of push them to the margins of life and make their life intolerable and that works, doesn't it? I mean people feel, the people who are still in the police feel they can't understand it but they're being pushed out and it's harder to recruit policemen and people start dropping out and whatnot. Yeah. So the numbers who are people over time begin to leave the police at a fairly significant rate and that becomes, and this is really important for the story as we'll tell it later on, but it's it leads to recruitment from England of the black and tans and of the auxiliaries who become notorious in Irish history.
卖给他们牛奶，不会卖给他们鸡蛋，基本上，在英国我们会用这样一个表达：你会把他们发配到考文垂，基本上就是把他们边缘化，让他们在社会上无路可走，令他们的生活难以忍受，而这确实起到了作用，不是吗？我的意思是，人们觉得……那些仍在警察局里的人感到无法理解，但他们正在被排挤，招募警察变得越来越困难，人们开始纷纷退出，诸如此类。是的。因此，随着时间的推移，离开警察局的人数以相当显著的速度增加，这成为了……这将对我们稍后要讲述的故事至关重要，但这导致了从英国招募“黑和坦”部队（Black and Tans）以及在爱尔兰历史上声名狼藉的辅助警察（Auxiliaries）。
But the fundamental place of the police in Irish society was destabilized through 1919, through that boycotting that you were talking about. But also when attacks, and it shouldn't be dismissed, I suppose, as well. I say the violence was low scale, but there were still 10 policemen shot right through the rest of 1919. And then by September, there are attacks and the soldiers are being shot. So there's a group of British soldiers on their way to a Methodist church. They're Welsh, aren't they?
不过，警察在爱尔兰社会中的根本地位在 1919 年通过你刚才谈到的抵制活动被瓦解了。而且，当发生袭击时——我想这也不应被忽视。我说暴力规模小，但在 1919 年剩下的时间里，仍然有 10 名警察被枪杀。到了 9 月，袭击发生了，士兵也开始遭到枪击。有一群英国士兵在去循道宗教堂的路上。他们是威尔士人，对吧？
Death and Shropshire. The Shropshire-like infantry. Yeah. And they go to the church to Methodist service. And they're ambushed by an IRA unit led by Liam Lynch and George Power. There's about 30 attackers, but they have six guns between them. So the rest have big sticks. So it's said that what they were trying to do there, they were going to take the
来自什罗普郡。什罗普郡轻步兵团。是的。他们去教堂参加循道宗礼拜。他们遭到了一支由利亚姆·林奇和乔治·鲍尔领导的爱尔兰共和军（IRA）部队的伏击。袭击者大约有 30 人，但他们之间总共只有六支枪。所以其余的人都拿着大棒。据说他们当时试图做的是，
men's rifles, not shoot anyone, not kill anyone. They arrived in two cars. There was an exchange of, there was a conflict emerged and one of the soldiers was shot and four were injured. So do you know what, I looked him up yesterday and it reminded me of two things. So his name was Private William Jones and he was from Carmarthen, so actually Tom you're right, some of them were Welsh. And he, that reminded me of two things. One, he'd just got out of a prisoner of war camp, he'd been held in a prisoner of war camp in Germany.
他们只是想夺走这些人的步枪，并不想射杀任何人，不想杀死任何人。他们分乘两辆汽车抵达。双方爆发了交火，冲突中一名士兵被中枪身亡，四人受伤。你知道吗，我昨天查了一下这件事，它让我想起了两件事。第一，他刚从一个战俘营出来，他曾被关押在德国的一个战俘营里。
And the second thing, he was only 20 years old. And almost all the people that we'll be talking about in this story are remarkably young. And we'll see that when it comes to the IRA and who's involved in the IRA on these things. And I think another point to make about what happened down in Fermoy with that incident is the fact that the local coroner's jury declined to record a verdict of murder because they said that they hadn't intended to be killed, that they were just there to take the arms. And that led to members of the British
第二件事，他年仅 20 岁。我们在这次故事中谈到的几乎所有人，都年轻得惊人。当谈到爱尔兰共和军以及谁参与了爱尔兰共和军的这些行动时，我们就会发现这一点。我想关于费莫伊发生的这起事件，另一个值得指出的点是，当地的验尸陪审团拒绝做出谋杀的裁决，因为他们说袭击者并没有杀人的意图，他们去那里只是为了夺取武器。这导致英国
military coming in and wrecking the shops of some of the people who had served on that jury. Paul, can I just give a shout out to anyone who wants more detail on these incidents to the Irish History podcast presented by Finn Dwyer, which I've been listening to in preparation for this. He has a huge series on the war of independence and I highly recommend it. I can't believe Tom's recommending a rival podcast. So a rival, it's a compliment. This is literally Tom's last appearance on the show to be clear.
军方人员随后闯入，砸毁了曾在该陪审团任职的一些人的店铺。保罗，我能向任何想要了解这些事件更多详情的人推荐芬·德怀尔（Finn Dwyer）主持的《爱尔兰历史播客》（Irish History podcast）吗？我在做准备时一直在听。他有一系列关于独立战争的宏大节目，我强烈推荐。我真不敢相信汤姆居然在推荐一个竞争对手的播客。好吧，竞争对手，这其实是一种赞美。需要明确的是，这绝对是汤姆在本节目的最后一次出场。
Right, so let's move on into, well let's look at the politics. So you mentioned the foundation of Doral Aron at the beginning of 1919. And the shadow government, I mean they are really doing stuff and they're gaining legitimacy throughout the course of the year, aren't they? Because they're doing things like they've staffed the government, they're raising money, they are dispensing justice. So just give us a quick overview of what they're doing there. So what they actually try and do is to put into operation in a state, despite the fact that they are continually harassed, particularly in the summer of
好了，让我们继续，嗯，让我们来看看政治局势。所以你提到了 1919 年初爱尔兰议会（Dáil Éireann）的建立。而这个影子政府，我的意思是他们确实在做事，而且随着这一年时间的推移，他们的合法性正在不断增强，不是吗？因为他们在做各种事情，比如他们组建了政府官员队伍，在筹集资金，在行使司法权。所以请给我们简要概述一下他们在那里做的事情。所以他们实际尝试做的是，在一个国家内部将政府职能投入运转，尽管他们不断受到骚扰——特别是在 1919 年的夏天
1919 and then suppressed, just as the Irish volunteers then renamed the Irish Republican Army, Tom, which gets you your IRA initials. So and Sinn Fein. So these are suppressed at that point. But so De Valera is back as president. That's an amazing story, isn't it? Because he's been sprung from Lincoln jail by, among others, Michael Collins in person. And it's an extraordinary story of how he gets there's a single key that
——然后被取缔，就在这时，爱尔兰志愿者部队被重新命名为爱尔兰共和军（Irish Republican Army），汤姆，这就成了你的“IRA”缩写。还有新芬党。所以他们在那个节点被取缔了。但埃蒙·德瓦莱拉作为总统回归了。这是一个了不起的故事，不是吗？因为他被迈克尔·柯林斯等人亲自从林肯监狱营救了出来。这是一个非凡的故事，讲他是如何……有一把单一的钥匙
opens all the doors and he makes a copy of the key, sends it off on a designer to people outside. They then make the key, send it in and there are kind of various attempts. They put it in a variety of cakes and finally De Valera gets out. Very hair raising stuff and again in Finn Dwyer's podcast, excellent account of that. And you can see it in death. So I should say, by the way, if you're doing shout outs, the Royal Irish Academy here, if people are interested in Irish history, all of the main characters that we're spoken about here, short biographies of them are available on the Dictionary of Iris biography, which is housed here at the Royal Irish Academy. It's free online and you get brilliant, brilliant descriptions of people's lives
打开了所有的门，他配制了一把钥匙的副本，通过设计将其送给外面的人。然后外面的人制作了这把钥匙并送了进来，期间有各种各样的尝试。他们把它藏在各种各样的蛋糕里，最后德瓦莱拉成功逃了出来。极其惊心动魄，同样在芬·德怀尔的播客里有精彩的叙述。你可以从中看出……顺便说一句，如果我要感谢致谢的话，这里的皇家爱尔兰学院，如果人们对爱尔兰历史感兴趣，我们这里讨论的所有主要人物的简短传记都可以在《爱尔兰传记词典》（Dictionary of Irish Biography）中找到，该词典就存放在皇家爱尔兰学院。它在网上是免费的，你可以从中读到从克雷格和卡森（由阿尔文·杰克逊撰写）等人物极其精彩的生平描述。所以真的非常棒。而且你在这里显得太谦虚了，因为你自己就写了其中的 99 篇。是的，我不认为这是写得更好的那些，我得承认。但我必须说，罗南·范宁（Ronan Fanning）和阿尔文·杰克逊（Alvin Jackson）等人写的内容非常精彩，本身就是极为出色的历史学术著作。但这些被书写的人——德瓦莱拉、柯林斯、格里菲斯、欧文·麦克尼尔和康斯坦斯·马凯维奇——他们现在领导着试图有所作为的各部委。他们有一位名叫
from Craig and Carson, which is done by Alvin Jackson onward. So really. And you'll be very modest here because you've written 99 of these yourself. Yeah, I don't want to think for the better ones, I have to say. But I have to say there were brilliant ones by people like Ronan Fanning and Alvin Jackson, which are utterly superb as pieces of historical scholarship in their own right. But these people who are written about, De Valera and Collins and Griffiths and Owen McNeill and Constance Markovich, they now head up ministries who are trying to do stuff. They have a secretary to a Dáil committee called
代尔莫特·奥哈加蒂（Dermot O'Hagarty）的爱尔兰议会委员会秘书，他同时也是爱尔兰议会的书记官，他们保存记录，组织内阁会议，进行沟通交流，并且确实在围绕各种事情开展工作，例如，他们募集了一笔五十万英镑的贷款。正是柯林斯在做这件事，对吧？是的，是柯林斯。因为他有这方面的背景，他曾在邮局工作过，后来又在会计事务所工作，所以他很擅长这类事情。
Dermot O'Hagarty who is the clerk of the Dáil as well and they keep records and they organize cabinet meetings and they have exchanges and they do actually do stuff around, they raise a loan for example, for half a million pounds. And it's Collins who's doing that, isn't it? Yeah, it's Collins. Because he's got this background, he worked in the post office and then an accountancy office so he's kind of good at this thing.
所以他是财政部长，但与此同时，他某种程度上也负责情报工作，不是吗？查尔斯·唐森（Charles Townsend）在他的书《共和国》中对此有过精彩的描述，书里提到他是“一个兼任行刑队队长的财政部长”，这具有不同寻常的优势。确实如此，而且有一个很精彩的笔记，在书的页边空白处提到，柯林斯
So he's the finance minister, but he's also at the same time kind of in charge of intelligence, isn't he? And there's a brilliant description of this by Charles Townsend in his book,'t he? And there's a brilliant description of this by Charles Tanzan in his book, The Republic, that he's a finance minister with the unusual advantage of running a death squad. Which, yeah, and it's there's a brilliant note actually in the margins where Collins
有着极具条理的头脑和极其出色的行政管理能力。因此，他从 15 万人那里筹集了这笔贷款。其中有渔业和试点计划，但当人们无法达到这些业务的运营标准时，他感到十分恼火。于是他放手不管了。德瓦莱拉对此有一个很好的批注，他在其中说道：
was a really organized mind and really, really brilliant administration. So he raised the money from the loan amount of 150,000 people. There were pilot schemes and fisheries in that, but he got exasperated when people weren't able to live up to the operations of these things. And he cut loose. And De Valera has a great note in it where he says,
“迈克尔，并不是每个人都有跟你一样条理分明的头脑。”所以他组织能力极强。你刚才关于行刑队的说法很关键，因为这笔资金是资助军队、运营渔业、土地和住房试点项目所必需的。但当时有一个来自土地战争时期的经验丰富的警察名叫艾伦·贝尔（Alan Bell）。艾伦·贝尔一直在追查这笔资金，穷追不舍。柯林斯知道他在追查这笔资金。于是柯林斯派出一个小队，当艾伦·贝尔乘有轨电车前往市中心时，将他枪杀。
Michael, not everybody has the same structured mind as you do. So he was really well organized. And so what you say there about the gun squad is important because this money was needed to fund the army and to run the pilot programs in fisheries and land and housing. But there was an experienced policeman from the Land War called Alan Bell. And Alan Bell was coming after this money and going after it and going after it. And Collins knew that he was going after it. And Collins had a unit that had him shot when he was coming in on a tram to the centre of the city.
所以这些事情……我认为对此同样值得注意的是，是的，他们在土地问题上所做的事情很重要，并尝试进行了一小部分土地分配；是的，地方政府的工作很重要；但其中的关键在于法院，他们建立了一个四级法院体系：堂区法院、轻罪法院、地区法院，甚至还有一个最高法院——一个由两名成员组成的最高法院。他们在当地发布罚款，将某些人驱逐出该地区，没收诸如私酿威士忌的蒸馏设备等物品，尤其是在农村地区。这象征着
So this is things, I think the other thing worth noting on this is yes it's important what they did with land and tried to do a small bit of land distribution. Yes it's important the local government stuff but the key thing in this is the courts, they established a court service which were four tiers, parish courts, minor crimes, district courts and actually a Supreme Court, a two member Supreme Court. And they issued fines in local areas, excluded people from being around the place, confiscated things like putsching stills, which were making illicit whiskey, particularly in rural areas. And what this is, it's symbolic of the withdrawal of allegiance. And the delegitimizing of British rule.
对忠诚度的收回，以及对英国统治合法性的剥夺。极其重要。伦敦的《每日先驱报》曾发表过这样一条评论，谈到这个“看不见的共和国，有着隐蔽的法院和被取缔的志愿者部队，存在于爱尔兰男女的心中，并发挥着国王乔治的所有坦克和机枪都无法号令的道德权威”，这才是关键所在，不是吗？因为他们无法指望赢得军事上的胜利，关键在于说服爱尔兰人这个共和国是真实存在的，但同时也得说服英国人……
Enormously important. Well, so there's this comment in the Daily Herald in London that refers to this invisible republic with its hidden courts and its prohibited volunteer troops, exists in the hearts of the men and women of Ireland and wields a moral authority which all the tanks and machine guns of King George cannot command and that's the key isn't it because they they can't hope to win a military victory it's about persuading the Irish that this Republic is real real but also persuading the British yeah that they can't hope to win I mean you could argue that's the whole strategy.
是的，让他们意识到自己无法指望获胜。你可以说，这整套策略就是如此。整套策略基本上就是向英国人表明他们永远无法获胜。因为他们无法通过开枪击败英国人，但他们可以彻底消磨英国人对这场冒险的信心。完全正确。而这其中至关重要的一点，也是要在全世界面前展示爱尔兰正在发生的事情。这就把我们带到了巴黎和平会议，你认为这真的很重要。哦，确实如此。它之所以重要，不仅在于人们对其本意的理解，更在于其象征意义。现在，我并没有完全深刻理解这一理念在世界范围内所具有的象征意义。去年，由丽莎·莫兰（Lisa Moran）博士等人主导，在爱尔兰
The whole strategy is to basically show the British that they can never win. Because they can't defeat the British by shooting them, but they can make the British lose heart in the whole enterprise. Exactly. And crucial to this as well is to show what's happening in Ireland in front of the world. So that takes us to the Paris Peace Conference, which you really think matters. Oh, it does. It matters because what isn't realised through it as much as what it was. Now, I didn't really understand at all in depth the symbolic importance of what was happening around the world to this idea. So there was a brilliant exhibition last year in the Irish
现代艺术博物馆举办了一场精彩的展览，展出了来自东欧各地、欧洲、波兰、乌克兰以及沿途各地的艺术作品，展示了在 1917 年至 1919 年间建立国家的那些所有小国。但它们每一个都是从破碎的帝国废墟中建立起来的。是的。它们来自哈布斯堡王朝。它们来自俄国革命。这就是为什么将爱尔兰的故事置于战后世界更广泛的欧洲背景中是如此重要。但使爱尔兰的故事与哈布斯堡王朝、奥斯曼帝国和俄国后帝国国家不同的是，爱尔兰是在向一个赢得了战争的国家、向一个正在获胜且正处于其力量巅峰的帝国寻求独立。
Museum of Modern Art, led out by Dr Lisa Moran, among others, which brought in these artistic works from all across Eastern Europe, from Europe, from Poland and Ukraine and everywhere along that thing to show all of those small nations that were establishing states in the years between 1917 and 1919. But every single one of them was being built from broken empires. Yeah. They're from the Habsburgs. They're from the Russian Revolution. And that's why it's so important to situate this story of Ireland in the broader European context of the post-war world. But what makes the Irish story different than the Habsburgs and the Ottomans and the Russian post
这是无法想象的。它去了巴黎。它派出了肖恩·T·奥凯利（Sean T. O'Kelly），我刚才说过他在 1916 年 12 月的早晨坐船抵达了那里。他带着妻子去见乔治·克莱门索，希望能求得一张会议桌席位，但未能如愿。他又通过威尔逊说：“听着，我们符合你们的十四点原则，给我们安排个桌前席位吧。”但这根本没有发生，因为如果爱尔兰退出联合王国，对英国而言意味着作为战争胜利者之一的联合王国，其领土损失将比被击败的德国还要大，而且不仅于此，还有另一件事——我认为在英国人心中极其重要的一点是，如果我们失去爱尔兰，那么埃及和印度就会紧随其后，因为在这一时期的所有动荡中，
empire states is that Ireland was looking for its independence from a state that had won the war, from an empire that was winning, that was now at the greatest extent of its power. Imaginable. And it went to Paris. It sent Sean T. O'Kelly, who I said had come in on the boat in December 1916 on the morning. He went there with his wife and rode to Georges Clemenceau looking for a seat at the table and couldn't get one. And went through Wilson and said, listen, we fit your 14 points, get us a seat at the table. And it just doesn't happen because the implication for Britain if Ireland leaves the United Kingdom is that the United Kingdom one of the victors in the war will end up with a greater loss of Territory than Germany which has been defeated and it's not just that by one other thing I mean, I think a massively important thing in the British minds is it if we lose Ireland then Egypt and India are next cuz they're in all this period
如果你查看英国报纸的头条，爱尔兰的风头往往会被埃及和印度的起义所盖过。因此，劳合·乔治等人心想，如果我们在这里做出退让，那么下一个就是印度。1919 年也是墨西哥埃米拉特（注：此处可能指埃米尔统治或相关动乱）的一年。没错。随后美国成为了焦点。因此，埃蒙·德瓦莱拉于 1919 年 6 月前往美国。巴黎的努力没有奏效。新芬党在选举中承诺的
There's cut that if you look at the headlines in British newspapers, often Ireland is actually dwarfed by what's happening in Egypt and India, by risings there. And so, Lloyd George and Co are thinking, if we concede on this, then India is next. 1919 is also the year of the Emirates on Mexico. Exactly. And America then becomes the focus. So, Eamon de Valera goes to America in June 1919. Paris hasn't worked out. All the promises of Sinn Fein from the election that
利用巴黎会议的企图现在已经破产了。所以德瓦莱拉去了美国。他大部分时间都住在纽约的华尔道夫酒店，但他的基本使命是推动各方对新爱尔兰共和国的承认并筹集资金。5 万人涌向波士顿红袜队的主场——伟大的芬威球场去听他演讲。他发起了一场公债认购运动，筹集了 550 万美元。但金钱实际上是他在那里取得的唯一真正成功，因为无论是民主党人还是共和党人在当年举行的各党派大会上最终都没有支持爱尔兰事业，原因当然是爱尔兰裔美国人一如既往地存在分歧。
they would use Paris is now gone. So De Valera goes to America. He stays most of the time in New York's Waldorf Astoria but he's basically on a mission to advance recognition for the new Irish Republican to raise money. 50,000 people go to the great baseball stadium Fenway Park where the Boston Red Sox play to hear him. He does a bond drive which raises 5.5 million dollars but money was really the only real success out there because neither Democrats nor Republicans ultimately supported the Irish cause at the at the conventions that were held in the year because of course Irish, as Irish America always is, was divided.
那里存在着人格争端和权力斗争，同时在策略上也存在分歧，而与此同时，当地的人们也在不断推进他们自己的诉求。所以德瓦莱拉去了那里，筹集了一些资金，但确实无法推动美国给予承认，从而迫使英国人表态：“好吧，我们需要给这些人独立。”就个人影响力而言，德瓦莱拉不在美国是否让柯林斯和其他人物获得了更大的领导地位？是的，在他离开期间，主要是柯林斯和格里菲斯在主事，尤其是柯林斯的声望日渐提高
There were personality disputes and power struggles and also a dispute over strategy while all the while there were local people advancing themselves. So De Valera goes there, raises some money, but really cannot drive the recognition from America to get the British to say, OK, we need to give these guys independence. And in terms of the personalities, does De Valera's absence in America enable Collins and other figures to attain a greater kind of leadership role? Yeah, while he's away, it's Collins and Griffith, but particularly Collins is growing in stature
当时存在着性格冲突、权力斗争以及关于战略的分歧，而与此同时，当地民众也在不断提升自我。因此，德瓦莱拉去了那里，筹集了一些资金，但实际上无法迫使美国给予承认，从而让英国人说，好吧，我们需要给予这些人独立。就性格而言，德瓦莱拉不在美国是否让柯林斯和其他人物获得了更重要的领导角色？是的，在他离开期间，主要是柯林斯和格里菲斯，尤其是柯林斯的地位日益提高
and importance. And of course, Collins straddles the two worlds in a way that De Valera now doesn't anymore. De Valera is much more on the, even though he had been out with a gun in 1916, that world is now back in the politics side of things where Collins absolutely straddles both sides of the movement. So with the failure to get a seat at the Paris Peace Talks, it's pretty obvious that if this struggle is going to be won, it's going to be won in Ireland. And there's obviously the propaganda, but there's also the labour movement, which plays a big part in this. There's a series of strikes, strikes and boycotts, I guess.
以及重要性。当然，柯林斯跨越了这两个世界，而现在德瓦莱拉已经不再这样了。德瓦莱拉更倾向于——尽管他在1916年也曾拿着枪上过战场——那个世界现在已经回到了政治那一侧，而柯林斯则绝对横跨了运动的两侧。因此，随着未能获得巴黎和会的席位，很明显，如果这场斗争要取得胜利，它就必须在爱尔兰取得胜利。这里显然有宣传工作，但也有劳工运动，它在其中扮演了重要角色。有一系列罢工，我想，罢工和抵制活动。
Well, there's the limerick Soviet, isn't there? There is, which is kind of a term which is bandied around a little bit. The key thing is the strikes that took place at various stages, four key strikes, I think one in support of conscription that we've talked about already in 1919, a general strike in Limerick against the imposition of a special military area where permits needed to come in and out. In the third one, a two-day strike in support of political prisoners and railway munitions strike, which ran from May to December 1920, an enormous strike. And then you have Dublin Dockers who refused to handle war material. So all of this had a huge impact later on the British ability to combat the IRA.
嗯，有利莫瑞克苏维埃（Limerick Soviet），不是吗？是的，这个词在一定程度上被到处提及。关键在于在各个阶段发生的罢工，四次关键罢工，我想一次是支持我们在1919年已经讨论过的征兵制，利莫瑞克反对实行需要出入证的特殊军事区的总罢工。第三次是支持政治犯的两天罢工，以及从1920年5月持续到12月的铁路军火罢工，这是一场规模巨大的罢工。然后是都柏林码头工人，他们拒绝搬运战争物资。所以所有这些对后来英国打击爱尔兰共和军（IRA）的能力产生了巨大的影响。
I should say, by the way, that there was the prospect of recognition from the USSR for the new Irish Republic. And it was what ended up actually happening was the doll got kind of recognition from the international socialist conference in Bern in February 1919 but it didn't move quick enough to secure the agreement with with Moscow and left it to live and instead it was Britain who actually smoothed over its relationships with Moscow which which stopped that recognition coming in the end.
顺便说一句，我应该指出，当时存在获得苏联对新爱尔兰共和国承认的前景。最终发生的情况是，国会（Dáil）在1919年2月获得了伯尔尼国际社会主义者会议的某种承认，但它行动不够快，没能与莫斯科达成协议，而是由列宁留下来，相反，实际上是英国出面理顺了与莫斯科的关系，最终阻止了这种承认的到来。
The Phidias Albion. So before we get to the break, you mentioned the IRA a couple of moments ago. So the IRA, that's the term now being used for the Irish volunteers. But it never becomes official, does it? I would say it's used always, but by 1920 it is the term, the Irish Republican Army, that's pushed out. The thing that struck me reading about this was, I mean, this is a slightly, it might seem an odd and indeed heretical comparison to Irish nationalists, but how similar the
费迪亚斯·阿尔比恩（The Phidias Albion）。所以在我们进入休息时间之前，你刚才提到了爱尔兰共和军。所以爱尔兰共和军，这就是现在用来指代爱尔兰志愿军的术语。但这从未成为官方名称，是吗？我想说它一直被使用，但到1920年，爱尔兰共和军（Irish Republican Army）这个词被推了出来。阅读这段历史时让我震惊的是——我的意思是，这对爱尔兰民族主义者来说可能是一个略显奇怪甚至异端的比较——加入爱尔兰共和军的人与加入准军事组织的人有多么相似，比方说在东欧，或者确实，一个非常著名的组织——自由军团（Freikorps），即同时期在波罗的海作战的德国准军事组织。所以这些人要么在战争中度过了几年，要么可能刚刚错过战争，渴望行动，并且有一种崇拜男子气概、英雄主义和虚张声势的文化。你认为这是一个公平的比较吗？所以有很多不同群体的人参与了爱尔兰共和军和
people who joined the IRA are to people who join paramilitary groups, let's say in Eastern Europe or indeed, a very famous one, the Freikorps, the German paramilitary groups fighting in the Baltic at the same time. So men who've either spent a couple of years in the war or perhaps have just missed it and are eager for action and there's a kind of cult of manliness and heroism and bravado. Is that a fair comparison do you think? So there are a lot of different groups of people who are involved in the IRA and
其辅助组织妇女爱尔兰军（Cumann na mBan），参与独立战争的男男女女。他们在当时遭到蔑视，被谴责为乌合之众、街头混混和无赖（gurriers）。无赖。无赖只是用来形容每个城镇的乌合之众的词，运动最高层还混入了一些知识分子。这就是当时的看法。它其实完全没有抓住正在发生的事情的重点。这是一场巨大的代际更迭。
its ancillary organisation in coming them on, men and women who were involved in the IRA and its ancillary organisation in coming them on, men and women who were involved in the War of Independence. And they were dismissed at the time and condemned as a rabble as corner boys and gurriers. Gurriers. Gurriers is just this phrase that's used to describe the rabble of every town and city with a few intellectuals thrown in at the top of the movement. That was the idea of it. And it really missed the point of what was happening. This is a huge generational shift.
我同意。我能看出你所说的那些组织与这些组织之间的相似之处。这些都是十几岁末和二十多岁的男女，他们大多数出生于1890年代。在很多情况下，他们识字，受过教育，有技能。他们有一群被剥夺了移民权的人——自大饥荒以来，伟大的爱尔兰安全阀一直是去纽约，去伦敦，
And I agree. I can see the parallels with those organisations that you're talking about. These are men and women in their late teens and in their 20s, most of whom had been born in the 1890s. They were in very many cases, they were literate, they were educated, they were skilled. They had a group of people who were denied emigration, which was the great Irish safety chute since the famine, was to go to New York, to go to London,
在晚些时候最终去澳大利亚，还有南非，以及阿根廷，实际上这是爱尔兰事务的一个巨大焦点，但这在战争期间被剥夺了，所以他们留了下来。但他们的成员跨度很大，从农场劳工和农场工人到医学生。同样，将他们联系在一起的往往是年龄。许多人经历过基督教兄弟会学校（Christian Brother School）的教育，但他们的成员跨度从农场劳工和农场工人到医学生。
to go ultimately to Australia in later times, and South Africa, and Argentina actually, a huge focus of Irish things, but that was denied them during the war, so they stayed around. But they spanned people from farm laborers and farm workers up to medical students. Again, it's age often that binds them together. Many had been through a Christian brother school, But they span people from farm labourers and farm workers up to medical students.
同样，将他们联系在一起的往往是年龄。许多人经历过基督教兄弟会学校的教育。我们其实应该谈谈这个，激进化以及历史是如何被看待的、如何在各地被教授的重要性。起义后在贝尔法斯特举行了一次绝妙的方法论会议，当时这家伙出现了，他是教育专员，他说他为爱尔兰感到担忧，因为似乎没有足够的历史来解决或者为每个事业奠定基础。换句话说，这里有一段人们希望将其撕裂的共享历史，而历史教学的性质在这里是一个饱受争议的空间。
Again, it's age often that binds them together. Many had been through a Christian Brother School education. We should actually have spoken about this, the importance of radicalisation and how history is perceived and how it was taught in various places. There was a brilliant Methodist conference in Belfast after the Rising where this guy turned up, he was a Commissioner of Education and he says he worried about Ireland because there didn't seem to be enough history to go around to solve or to base every cause on it. In other words, there was a shared history here which people wish to pull apart and the nature of the teaching of history was a contested space here.
因此，叛乱委员会（Commission on the Rebellion）曾说过，三一学院（Trinity）的教务长马哈菲（Mahaffey）以及英国都柏林城堡（British Castle）的官员也反复说过，这里的一个巨大问题是爱尔兰国立学校以及后来的基督教兄弟会所教授的叛乱历史以及对英格兰性和英国性的排斥。所以这潜伏在背景中。有我们开始时提到的那些民谣。那在当时不是民谣，但在那之前你有一些像《再次成为国家》（A Nation Once Again）这样的东西。当马克维奇（Markovic）回来时，人们唱的就是《再次成为国家》。保罗，我能用一个英国习语向你投出一个“半截击球”（half ollie）吗？
So it was said in the Commission on the Rebellion and repeatedly by people like Mahaffey, who is the Provost of Trinity, and by British Castle officials that a huge problem here was the history of rebellion and a rejection of Englishness and of Britishness that was taught in the Irish national schools and then by its Christian brothers. So that's lurking there in the background. There are the ballads that we started with. That wasn't a ballad at the time, but before that you had stuff like A Nation Once Again. It's A Nation Once Again that's sung when Markovic comes back. And Paul, can I bowl you up a half ollie to use an English phrase?
体育，对吧？是的。我们可能在第三集里会稍微谈谈体育，当谈到血腥星期日（Bloody Sunday）以及克罗克公园（Croke Park）在血腥星期日发生的事情时。但它是什么呢？它是对英国体育革命的爱尔兰式模仿。英国体育革命看到了人们——我们知道在每个社会中人们一直都在进行体育运动——在英国体育革命中，你拥有的是比赛的规范化，他们将它们挤压到一个现代的运动场上。你会看到板球的传播，这是18世纪70年代和80年代爱尔兰最受欢迎的场地运动。
The sport, isn't it? There is. We'll probably when in the third episode talk a little bit about sport when it comes to Bloody Sunday and what happened in Croke Park on Bloody Sunday. But what it is, is an Irish imitation of the English sporting revolution. The English sporting revolution which saw the construction, people have always played sport, we know that across every society, and in the English sporting revolution what you have is the formalisation of games and they're squeezing them into a modern playing field. And you get the spread of cricket, most popular field game in
我们将制作一集专门讨论这个话题。橄榄球和足球，橄榄球和足球也传播开来，但盖尔运动协会（GAA）将那场革命颠覆了，通过建立盖尔运动协会来培育和保护爱尔兰的民族消遣，并创立了一项运动，发明了一项被称为盖尔式足球（Gaeilge football）的运动，以对抗其他运动，并为现代重新构想了爱尔兰式曲棍球（hurling）运动。在我结束关于盖尔运动协会的讨论之前，我应该说，为什么盖尔运动协会在这种革命背景下很重要，是因为有像迈克尔·柯林斯（Michael Collins）、哈里·博兰（Harry Boland）和JJ·沃尔什（JJ Walsh）这样的人，他们通过在盖尔运动协会内部的领导层磨练了他们的行政技能，并获得了声望和自信，这赋予了他们随后可以在其他地方使用的地位。保罗，在我们进入休息时间之前还有一件事。你谈到了男人和女人。是的。为了顺应多米尼克（Dominic）将这种情况与德国局势进行类比，罗莎·卢森堡（Rosa Luxemburg）就是一个例子，表明战后女性正在挺身而出，在革命运动中扮演比战前任何时候都更为突出的角色，
Ireland in the 1870s and in the 80s. We'll be doing an episode on exactly this. Rugby and soccer, rugby and soccer as well spread but the GAA turned that revolution on its head and by founding the Gaelic Athletic Association for the cultivation and preservation of the Irish National Pastimes and founded a game, invented a game which had called Gaelic football in opposition to others and reimagined the game of hurling for a modern era. I should say before I finish on the GAA, why the GAA matters in this context of revolution is there are people like Michael Collins and Harry Boland and JJ Walsh who learn their administrative skills and come to
爱尔兰也正在发生同样的事情，不是吗？我们讨论过马克维奇伯爵夫人（Countess Markievicz），但还有其他人。好吧，所以在爱尔兰独立战争中，女性在多个方面都很重要。她们是——在各个阶段来自双方的暴力受害者的确是事实，有些女性的头部被剃光，在这个时期也是强奸的受害者。应该说，双方都存在有辱人格的对待。有些女性参与了爱尔兰共和军。在谈论爱尔兰共和军时，记住这一点非常重要：爱尔兰共和军的大多数成员并没有开枪。
prominence and confidence through leadership within the Gaelic Athletic Association and it gives them a status which they can then use elsewhere. And Paul, one other thing before we come to the break. You talked about men and women. Yes. And to pursue Dominic's analogy with the situation in Germany, Rosa Luxemburg, an example of the way that women in the aftermath of the war are stepping forwards and taking a much more prominent role in revolutionary movements than they would ever have done
她们是为了后勤支持而在那里的。她们可能参与间谍活动。她们可能参与枪支走势、情报提供，以及所有与之相关的辅助支持。在那些年里，女性做了所有这些事情。她们对宣传也至关重要。所以你会看到像玛丽（Mary）和穆里尔·麦斯威尼（Muriel McSweeney）这样的人，玛丽的兄弟以及穆里尔的丈夫，他在担任科克（Cork）市长期间死于绝食抗议。
before the war and the same thing is happening in Ireland isn't it? We've talked about Countess Mouchavitz but there's there are others as well. Okay so women matter in the Irish War of Independence in multiple ways. They are it is true the victims of violence at various stages from both sides you have women who get their head shaved and are also the victim of rapes during this period. There is degrading treatment on both sides, it should be said. There are women who are involved in the IRA. It is so important to remember when you talk about the IRA, the majority of members of the IRA didn't fire a gun.
所以在泰伦斯·麦斯威尼（Terrence McSweeney）死后，她们去了美国，并进行了一场筹款活动。玛丽在58个城市的300场会议上发表了讲话，她的最新传记——或者由利安·莱恩（Leanne Lane）为她写的传记——非常出色地将其描述为一系列人物，她接续在罗莎蒙德·雅各布（Rosamund Jacob）等人之后出现，这些人都是构建一种超越了那些十几岁末和二十岁出头男孩的民族主义世界的中心人物。
They were there for logistical support. They may be involved in espionage. They may be involved in the trafficking of guns in the provision of intelligence, all the ancillary supports that are involved in that. And women did all of those things during those years. And they were also fundamental to propaganda. So you see people like Mary and Muriel McSweeney, whose brother in Mary's case and whose husband in Muriel's case, he died on hunger strike while he was Lord Mayor of Cork.
好了，让我们回到叙事中来。我们仍然停留在1919年，正如我们所听到的，国会正在筹集资金，爱尔兰共和军正在招募所有这些年轻人，组织里有女性，宣传工作在不断转化受众，罢工已经获得了势头。但到目前为止，如果你经历过西线战场的战斗，这绝对不像是一场全面战争，而这一切在我们进入1920年且死亡人数开始上升时将发生改变，所以我们将在休息后讲述故事的另一面。你好，我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），嗨，我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osmond），我们是另一档精彩的Goalhanger节目的主持人，
So they went to the United States after the death of Terrence McSweeney and they went on a fundraising campaign through. Mary spoke to 300 meetings in 58 cities and, the most recent biography of her, or the biography of her written by Leanne Lane, does this brilliantly as a series of, she comes on from people, after people like Rosamund Jacob, who are all women who are central to this world of kind of the construction of a nationalism which goes way beyond just those boys who are in their late teens and early twenties.
《娱乐至上》（The Rest is Entertainment）。每周，理查德和我都会谈论我们最喜欢的娱乐新闻故事以及令人难以置信的幕后花絮。比如，通常当人们做播客时，他们是在读一张纸上的内容。好吧，当他们做预告片时。你不能不把幕布拉开，对吧？你现在就在把它拉开。
All right, well let's get back to the narrative. We're still in 1919, so as we've heard the Doyle is raising money, the IRA are recruiting all these young men, there are women in the organization, the propaganda, making converts, the strikes have gained momentum. But so far, if you've been through the fighting on the Western front this does not look like an all-out war by any means and that's all going to change when we get through into 1920 and the death toll begins to mount so we will do that side of the story after the break. Hello I am Marina Hyde and hi I'm Richard Osmond and we are the hosts of another great Goal Har show,
等等，我正要读一张纸上的内容。现在，我们对《大白鲨》（Jaws）混乱拍摄过程的两部分深度剖析，对我们的俱乐部会员来说已经具有绝对巨大的吸引力。玛丽娜，他们一直称其为我们有史以来最好的额外单集之一。所以如果你像我一样，在观看了史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格（Steven Spielberg）的这部经典之作后，依然害怕下水，那么你需要收听这个系列。我们深入探讨了为什么这是一部如此混乱且几乎致命的制作的难以置信的细节，从暴动的剧组、叛逆的演员，到不断抛锚的机械鲨鱼。
the rest is entertainment. Each week, Richard and I talk about our favourite entertainment news stories and incredible behind the scenes facts. Like for example, often when people do podcasts, they are reading off a bit of paper. Well, when they do the trailers. You cannot not draw the curtain back, can you? You're drawing it back right now.
在有限的时间内，所有Goalhanger播客听众都可以通过访问therestisentertainment.com独家访问我们完整的《大白鲨》系列。什么？是的，完全免费。我们甚至在这个我们正在谈论的任何播客的结尾留下了我们关于《大白鲨》的第一集的一点预告。也许节目是《金钱至上》（The Rest is Money），也许是《历史至上》（The Rest is History）。或者前往therestisentertainment.com，免费收听整套《大白鲨》系列。你好，欢迎回到《历史至上》。我们以一首带点泪眼朦胧的、在多米尼克看来，
Wait, I'm about to read off a bit of paper. Now, our two-part deep dive into the chaotic making of Jaws has already been absolutely massive with our club members. They've been calling it, Marina, one of our best bonus episodes ever. So if you, like me, are still terrified of getting into the water after seeing that Steven Spielberg classic on I Am, then you need to hear this series. We dive into the unbelievable details of why it was such a chaotic and almost killer production from rioting crew, rebelling actors, a robot shark that kept breaking down.
是对逃亡自由战士的矫情民谣开场。但实际上，保罗，到目前为止在本集里，我们经历的战斗非常少。这基本上就像是美国西部的枪战。那么节奏是如何开始加快的呢？英国人什么时候开始意识到他们正身处一场战争中？保罗·奥吉尔（Paul O'Day）——到了1920年初，战争开始变得更加激烈。因此，爱尔兰共和军开始追击警察局。到1920年复活节时，全国各地有350个警察局被摧毁。而爱尔兰皇家警察（RIC），即爱尔兰警察，基本上只能撤退到较大的城镇。除此之外，大约有30个法院被拆毁、摧毁，地方税务局也是如此。
For a limited time, all Goalhanger Podcast listeners can get exclusive access to our complete Jaws series. What? Yes, absolutely free by visiting therestisentertainment.com. We've even left a little taste of our first episode on Jaws at the end of this whatever podcast we're talking. Maybe the rest is money, maybe the rest is history. Or go to therestisentertainment.com and dive into the whole Jaws series for free. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We opened with a misty-eyed, and in the opinion of Dominic,
他们对我们其余人隐瞒了这一点。所以这就是英国国家的退却。但这里有个问题。汤姆说，英国人什么时候——他们什么时候才意识到这是一场战争？正如我们将要发现的，在这个故事的整个过程中，有人基本上一直在反驳这是一场战争的说法。
a mawkish ballad about freedom fighters on the run. But actually, Paul, so far in this episode, we've had very little fighting. It's basically been Wild West shootouts. So how does the pace start to pick up? When do the British start to realise they're in a war? Paul Ogier – By the time you get to early 1920, the war is beginning to get much more fierce. So the IRA go after police barracks. And by the Easter 1920, there are 350 police barracks around the country, which have been destroyed. And the RIC, the Irish police, basically have to withdraw to just the larger towns. On top of that, there was about 30 courthouses, which are demolished, destroyed, and local taxation offices too.
有一种英国强硬派、顽固派，他们说我们面对的是一场谋杀运动。这纯粹是犯罪活动。这些人就是——这就是我们所面临的，这是一场谋杀运动，这纯粹是犯罪活动，而这些人是，你知道的，这就是我们所面临的，这是一个法律与秩序的问题。接着这一点，英国的权力是通过警察部队还是通过军队来投射的？通过警察部队，但随后警察部队证明无力做到这一点，而且军队也一直在周围。
And they kept that from the rest of us. So this is the retreat of the British state. But here's a question. Tom said, when does the British ever, when does it strike them that it's a war? And as we'll find out, there are people all through this story who basically dispute that it is a war.
所以我不会把一个和另一个分开，我认为你应该把这一切作为一个整体来看待，作为王室军队。但这被视为一个治安问题。这被视为一个治安问题，这也是问题所在，因为治安问题发生的情况是警察无法应付。正如你刚才提到的，多米尼克，他们正在离开这个组织。到1920年夏天，每周大约有50名警察离职。你需要在某处进行招募。所以他们做的是从英国招募失业士兵。他们以每周大约100人的速度这样做，直到1920年6月。
There are kind of British hardliners, diehards, who say we're facing a murder campaign. This is a criminality, pure and simple. And these people are, this is what we're facing. murder campaign, this is a criminality pure and simple and these people are, you know, this is what we're facing, it's a law and order issue. Just to follow up on that, British power is being projected through the police force or through the army? Through the police force but then the police force proves unable to do it and the army is around the place as well always.
这些新士兵或这些新警察穿着独特的卡其色和绿色、深绿色制服。他们在爱尔兰历史中作为“黑棕民兵”（Black and Tans）而闻名。这也是这场独立战争所使用的术语之一，即“坦战争”（Tan War），因为在公众心目中，他们所做的一些事情被人们铭记了下来。在1920年夏天，另一个参与治安的至关重要的群体也加入了进来，被称为“辅助部队”（Auxiliaries）。这些主要前英国军队的军官。
So I wouldn't separate one from the other, I think you look at it all in the round as Crown forces. But it's seen as a policing issue. It's seen as a policing issue and that's the problem as well because what happens with the policing issue is that the police are unable to cope. As you mentioned earlier Dominic they are leaving the organisation. There are about 50 policemen a week leaving by the summer of 1920. You need to get recruitment somewhere. So what they do is they recruit unemployed soldiers from Britain. And they do that at a rate about 100 a week until June 1920.
在两支部队之间，你面对的可能大约有10,000人，他们在爱尔兰历史中，以及根据当时的报道在现实中，以他们的残暴、酗酒以及在某些地方标志着他们部分行为的无节制暴力而闻名。所以这里的平行点，我想说，再次与东欧发生的事情相似，在那里你有大量的前军人加入准军事组织，基本上，通常是因为他们失业了，因为第一次世界大战结束时出现了巨大的经济低迷。他们需要一份工作，他们想要固定的薪水，他们喜欢穿制服，他们喜欢带枪。但同时，我的意思是，我认为这是所有这些故事中总是被低估的一点。对许多这些人来说，这很有趣。它给他们一种关怀感。我的意思是，就像加入任何准军事组织一样，它给你一种兄弟情谊、归属感、兴奋感以及所有这些类型的感觉。他们自己也这么说。他们在20世纪60年代为各种电视纪录片后来录制的采访中这样说过，比如，其中一个人在1920年初正前往加入法国军团，报酬非常少。
And these new soldiers or these new policemen wear distinctive khaki and green, dark green uniforms. And they become famous in Irish history as the Black and Tans. And this is one of the terms that is used for this war of independences, the Tan War, because in the popular mind, it's remembered some of the things that they did. They are joined also in the summer of 1920 by another crucial group who were involved in again in policing called the Auxiliaries. And these are mainly former officers within the British
然后他说，这里的薪水很好。我要加入这个。这会让我再次回归友情。他在军队里生活了多年的那个世界，现在在爱尔兰的不同背景下被重现了。汤姆，你刚才说得对，这不是索姆河（Somme）或凡尔登（Verdun）的战场。这是完全相反的情况。
Army. And between both of those forces, you're looking at possibly around 10,000 people and they are famous within Irish history and in reality from the reports at the time for their brutality, for their drunkenness and for the unrestrained violence, which characterised some of their behaviour in some places. So here the parallel, I would say, is again with what's happening in Eastern Europe, where you have large numbers of ex-servicemen joining paramilitary groups, basically, often because they're unemployed, because there's
这把人们逼疯了，因为他们不知道敌人会从哪里出现，他们从树篱里钻出来。他们融入民众中。他们从民众中来，杀人，然后又回到民众中。这是一种新型战争吗？在爱尔兰的背景下，是的，它是。这是一种新型战争。它被视为——并且被看作是一种原型游击战，
been a massive economic downturn at the end of the First World War. They need a job, they want regular pay, they like having a uniform, they like carrying a gun. But also, I mean, this is a thing that I think is always underappreciated in all these stories. For a lot of these men, it's fun. It gives them a sense of care. I mean, rather like joining any paramilitary group, it gives you a sense of brotherhood and belonging and excitement and all of these kinds of things. And they say this. They say this in interviews which were recorded later in the 60s for various television documentaries, where, for example, there's one who was on his way to join the French Legion in early 1920 for a really small sum of money.
随后在不同的国家被采用。我不是一个足够优秀的军事史学家，不敢说这是一种开创性的战斗方式。但它融入民谣以及我们一直在谈论的所有其他事物的方式，确实给人一种感觉，即英国人正在面对一种任何军事化军队都未曾面过的战斗形式。这在一定程度上必定是他们难以找到应对策略的原因，因为没有任何军队不得不处理类似的事情。是的，但不仅仅是这样。他们受到了都柏林城堡和总督府领导质量的严重辜负。因此，法国元帅（Lord French）当时是陆军元帅。
And then he goes, the pay here is good. I'm going to join this. It'll put me into fellowship again. That world which he had lived in in the army for years is now recreated in a different context in, in, in Ireland. Now you're right in what you said earlier, Tom, this is not the battlefields of the Sommeam or Verdon. This is the complete opposite.
现在，他的姐姐夏洛特·德斯帕特（Charlotte Desparte）实际上正全力投入共和党运动，这对他没有什么帮助。直到为时已晚，他才开始认真对待共和党人。他在1920年12月遭到枪击——或者说在1920年12月险些被枪杀。但你拥有像伊恩·麦克弗森（Ian MacPherson）、爱德华·斯科特（Edward Scott）这样的人，他们被任务的性质彻底压垮了。以至于英国公务员工头、沃伦·费舍尔爵士（Sir Warren Fisher）被派往都柏林城堡查看城堡是如何运作的。他写了一份报告，对城堡的性质进行了严厉的抨击。
And it drives people crazy that they do not know where the enemy is coming from, that they're coming from hedges. They melt from the population. They come from it, they kill and they go back into it. And is this a new kind of warfare? In the Irish context, yes, it is. It is a new kind of warfare. It is seen and it is seen as kind of a prototype guerrilla warfare,
他说它的行事方式简直是愚蠢至极。所以你面临这样一种情况：你有一个行将崩溃的行政机构，然后你没有统一的军事指挥权，因为警察和军队是分开的，而且这一点很不明确。然后在这个的最顶层，是一个不知道该做什么的政府。他们摇摆不定，一会儿说“如果某个地区有人被杀，我们将允许报复”，一会儿又说“我们不会走绝对追捕所有人并烧毁这个地方的路线”。
which is then taken on in different countries afterwards. I'm not enough of a military historian to say that this is some sort of a pioneering way of fighting. But the way in which it's kind of joined in with the ballads and everything else that we've been talking about, there is a sense, isn't there, that the British are confronting a form of combat that no militarized army has faced before. And this in part must be why they struggle to get a handle on a strategy for coping with it because no army has had to deal with something like this. Yes but it's more than that as well. They are singularly failed by the quality of the leadership in Dublin Castle and in the Viceroy. So Lord French was the Field Marshal at the time.
所以它陷入了一种摇摆不定的状态。这就是让我感到震惊的一点，如果你在批评英国的战略，英国人要么——我想说——不进行任何报复，你试着用仁慈去感化，或者你有点像车臣的俄罗斯人，你直接冲进去说：“听着，我们只想杀死尽可能多的人，直到完成任务，我们的武力远比你们强大。”而实际上，英国人完全落在了这两个立场的中间。他们永远不会选择那种彻底残暴、无所不用其极的做法。多米尼克，他们不能。他们不能。
Now, he wasn't helped by the fact that his sister Charlotte Desparte was actually in full swing with the Republican movement. He failed to take the Republicans seriously until it was too late. And he was shot in December 1920 or shot at in December 1920 and almost killed. But you had people like Ian MacPherson and Edward Scott and people like that who were just overwhelmed by the nature of their task. So much so that the head of the British Civil Service, Sir Warren Fisher, was sent to Dublin Castle to have a look at how the castle was run. And he wrote a report, which is savage, on the nature of the castle.
他们没有合法性，他们在国内没有支持。即使他们想这么做，我想他们也会受到抑制。除其他外，他们无法向美国交代。而且由于英国的公众舆论，他们也做不到。确切地说。因为英国有足够多的人对正在发生的事情感到震惊。工党派遣代表团，曼彻斯特卫报（Manchester Guardian）充满了反对正在发生的事情的文章。但他们仍然在进行足够的报复，以至于把爱尔兰的舆论推向了对立面。
He said it was almost woodenly stupid how it did, how it conducted its affairs. So you have a situation whereby you have a creaking administration and then you don't have a unified military command because the police and the army are separate and they it's not quite clear. And then you have at the top of this, a government who does not know what to do. And they've oscillate between, oh, we'll allow for reprisals if someone's killed in an area, but we're not going to go down the route of absolutely going after everybody here and raising the place.
并且确实是一些地方性的残暴行为。科克的毁灭、巴尔布里根（Balbriggan）的洗劫、其他各种地方。罗斯康 común郡的博伊尔（Boyle）、克莱尔郡的拉辛奇（La Hinch）、凯里的特拉利（Trilly）和利斯托尔（Listole）镇。当黑棕民兵或辅助部队到达时，你会看到这些地方遭到浩劫。西利弗·麦克里迪爵士（Sir Neville MacReady）有一段精彩的评论，他在1920年初被任命为爱尔兰最高军事指挥官，他对局势极其悲观。在这场战役的整个过程中，他一直在说这太糟糕了。他说无论我们做什么，我们都肯定会错——我的意思是他是对的。但世界已经改变了，就像他们的世界已经改变了一样，而且英国国家也对战争感到无比厌倦，并且正处于财务动荡之中。很明显，如果你想在这里维持一支真正庞大的军队，它将花费你大量你未必想花的资金。
So it gets caught in a swinging boat ways. So this is one thing that strikes me, that if you're criticizing the British strategy, the British are either you don't do any reprisals, I would say, and you try to kill with kindness, or you're sort of, you know, the Russians in Chechnya and you just go in and say, listen, we're just going to kill as many people as it takes, we'll get this done, and we have far more force than you do. And actually, the British completely fall between those two stalls. They're never going to go for the sort of utterly brutal, everything. They can't, Dominic. They can't.
与此同时，没有明显的政治解决方案。正如多米尼克所说，埃及和印度的殖民地局势也可能实际上被赋予更高的优先级。是的。在那些局势不断恶化，或者除非你在这些局势上达到某个特定的点之前，你不能被认为失去了爱尔兰，他们进退维谷。他们不知道该做什么。他们的合法性在全国大部分地区已经被彻底摧毁。所以让我们进入1920年夏天。我们以提到“我在1916年加入了飞行纵队”开场。你当时不可能加入飞行纵队，因为那时他们还没有。但从1920年夏天开始，他们确实有了。为什么飞行纵队很重要？
They don't have the legitimacy, they don't have the support, a home. They're inhibited, I think, from doing it even if they wanted to. They can't do it with America apart from anything else. And they can't do it because of British public opinion. Exactly. Because there's enough people in Britain who are appalled at what's going on. The Labour Party sends over delegations, the Manchester Guardian is filled with articles of people opposing what's happening. But they're still doing enough reprisals to turn opinion against them in Ireland.
为什么它们改变了局势？当然，民谣的伟大之处在于它们不必拘泥于历史，它们营造出一种氛围和一个理念。我们营造出一种——它们不必拘泥于历史，它们营造出一种氛围和一个理念。我们营造出氛围，但我们也拘泥于历史，所以我们的播客比民谣更好。所以爱尔兰共和军正在改变他们的战术，是这样吗？是的，他们正在改变战术，他们开始四处逃亡，他们正在获得更多的武器，他们的武器是从美国各地走私进来的，他们试图从美国获得汤姆逊冲枪，这些枪通过利物浦运进来。
And really kind of localised brutal acts. The destruction of Cork, the sacking of Balbriggan, various other places. Boyle in County Roscommon, La Hinchin County, Clare, the towns of Trilly and Listole and Kerry. You get these havoc wrought by the Black and Tans or the Auxiliaries when they arrive in. There's a magnificent comment by Sir Neville MacReady, who gets appointed Supreme Military Commander in Ireland in early 1920 and he is comically pessimistic. The whole way through this campaign he's kind of saying it's all awful. He says whatever we do we are sure to be wrong and I mean he's right. But the world had changed, like their world had changed and the British state was also
英格兰和苏格兰的爱尔兰共和军正在运送武器过来，资金也在源源不断地涌入，所以情况稍微好了一点。军队的情报比以前好得多，由迈克尔·柯林斯在情报战中领导，这真的非常非常重要。
incredibly sick of war and it was in financial turmoil as well. And it was right really clear that if you want to keep a really major army in the field here, it's going to cost you a lot of money that you don't necessarily want to spend. And all the while, there's no obvious political solution. And also there are, as Dominic said, colonial situations in Egypt and in India, which may actually be prioritised. Yes. And you can't be seen to lose Ireland significantly while those situations are
他设法收编了都柏林城堡侦探部门的四名低级成员，主要是大卫·内利根（David Nelligan）和爱德华·布雷（Ned Bray），他们为他提供了名字和灵感，这场情报战至关重要，因为这其中也有女性参与。还有打字员，对吧？是的，有打字员，还有更广泛地在都柏林城堡工作的人。总局（GPO）也有打字员，南希·奥布莱恩（Nancy O'Brien），她是柯林斯的表妹，还有在火车上工作或传递信息的人。1919年中期，都柏林成立了一个特别部队，他们在那里杀害了各种各样的人。
unravelling or unless you get to a certain point with them, they're in the horns of a dilemma. They don't know what to do. Their legitimacy has been utterly destroyed in large sections of the country. So let's go through to the summer of 1920. We started with that mention of, I joined the flying column in 1916. You couldn't have joined a flying column then because they didn't have them. But they do have them from summer 1920. Why did the flying columns matter?
这在整个1920年代确实在蓬勃发展。这是一支正在发展其力量的军队。它在各地派遣飞行纵队。现在必须说的是，暴力的发生是非常地域化的，有些郡的暴力极其猛烈且成功，而其他郡在这些年里根本没有真正的行动。这仅仅是因为该运动是一种自下而上的运动，而不是自上而下的运动吗？是的，这是不可能的。都柏林并不控制爱尔兰共和军在全国各地发生的事情。爱尔兰共和军在当地做什么，虽然有沟通和武器流动，但总的来说，这取决于地方指挥官如何运作，而这不是一个简单的行动。
Why do they change things? So of course, the great thing about ballads are that they don't have to be slavish to history, they create an atmosphere and an idea. We create an they don't have to be slavish to history they create an atmosphere and an idea. We create an atmosphere but we're also slavish to history, so our podcasts are better than ballads. So the IRA are changing their tactics, is that what they're doing? Yes, they are changing their tactics and they go on the run and they're getting more arms, their arms have been run in from around America, they try to get Tommy guns from America which
所以谈论爱尔兰共和军及其在基层的活动，把我们带到了整个话题中最具争议的问题。这就是暴力是否具有宗派主义性质的问题。我知道关于爱尔兰历史写得最具争议的书大概是彼得·哈特（Peter Hart）的《爱尔兰共和军及其敌人》（The IRA and Its Enemies），他出版了这本开创性的书，遭到了很多批评，他在书中说：这是战斗中被低估和抹杀的一个方面，那就是存在大量的宗派暴力，在某些地区，新教徒是其中的受害者。当然，有数量惊人的……
come across through Liverpool. The IRA in England and in Scotland are sending arms over and there's money coming through, so there's a little bit more there. The Army, its intelligence is much better than it was previously, run by Michael Collins in Intel war, which was really, really important.
我们应该说，北方毫无疑问存在数量惊人的宗派暴力，双方都在实施暴力，但天主教徒是主要的受害者。但就爱尔兰共和军及其暴力而言，你认为其中有宗派主义的成分吗？我认为你不能一方面指出宗教对于一百年前的爱尔兰身份和更广泛身份至关重要，另一方面又假装爱尔兰独立战争中发生的事情没有宗派主义成分。我并不是有一分钟说这是一场宗派战争，我也不希望这被错误地定性，但要想象爱尔兰共和军中没有那些有宗派主义倾向、极其厌恶新教徒、被排斥在土地所有权或权力和财富职位之外、继承了一段他们的人民和宗教的土地被剥夺的历史的人，我认为这是对现实的否定。我认为问题在于——而且必须在个人基础上提出——在导致他们加入爱尔兰共和军并随后杀人的过程中，某人受宗派主义动机或其他冲动的驱使程度如何。你会发现在许多爱尔兰民谣中，内容全都是为了爱尔兰而死。
He managed to get four junior members of the detectives in Dublin Castle, basically the turn notably Ned Bray and David Nelligan, and they gave him names and inspiration and this intelligence war is vital because there are women in this as well. And there are typists, aren't there? Yeah, there are typists and there's people who work in Dublin Castle more generally. And there are typists in the GPO, Nancy O'Brien, who is a cousin of Collins, and people who work on the trains or passing information. And a special unit is set up in Dublin in mid 1919 in which they kill various people.
没有人真正想谈论为了爱尔兰而杀戮，但杀戮对那些实施杀戮的人的生活显然产生了巨大的影响。这对人们来说是一场极其艰难的对话。关于彼得·哈特，当时我正坐火车去贝尔法斯特。大约是20年多前，差不多吧，我最后和坐在我对面的人聊了起来，那是人们在手机真正普及之前还习惯在火车上互相交谈的时期。我和这个加拿大人聊得很开心。大约半小时后，真的，
And that really is flourishing through the 1920s. And this is an army which is developing its power. It runs flying columns around the place. Now it has to be said that it was very localized the violence where there were some counties where it was extremely potent and successful and other counties where there was no real action at all during these years. And is that just because the movement is a kind of bottom up movement rather than top down? Yes, it's impossible. Dublin does not run what's happening in the IRA around the country. What the IRA does locally. There is communication and there are weapons flows, but broadly speaking it's up to local commandants to run them and that's not a straightforward operation.
因为我显然不是史上最伟大的侦探，我意识到他是彼得·哈特。我们要去贝尔法斯特参加一个会议，我也要在会上发言。按照这种事情的规律，他是一个非常非常好的家伙。在去会议的路上，我们去喝了一品脱啤酒，你会这么做的。缓和一下紧张气氛。午餐时间的贝尔法斯特是非常愉快的。我们转过街角走进会议现场，外面有人在抗议他。他们设立了一个桌子。他们在分发反对他、反对他的书以及他对历史的解读的资料。
So talking about the IRA and its activities on the ground brings us to probably the single most controversial question of this whole subject. This is the issue of whether the violence is sectarian. And I know probably the most contentious book ever written about Irish history by Peter Hart, The IRA and Its Enemies, he published this groundbreaking book, they took a lot of criticism in which he said, this is an aspect of the fighting that has been undervalued and kind of erased, which is there's a lot of sectarian violence, and Protestants are the victims of it in some areas. Of course, there's an awful lot of...
所以他们认为这项工作是对爱尔兰共和军遗产的恶毒攻击，特别是在科克。所以彼得·哈特所做的是，他写了一篇关于独立战争期间科克爱尔兰共和军的研究报告。在很大程度上，这是一本极好的书。它提供了对社会阶层的研究，围绕暴力提供了统计基础，以及围绕真正非常强有力的原创学术成果的一切。其中两个具有争议的部分，大体上来说，是一次基尔米凯尔伏击（Kilmichael ambush），这是一次由一个叫汤姆·巴里（Tom Barry）的人领导的重大伏击。
We should say there's an awful lot of sectarian violence undoubtedly in the North, in which both sides are carrying it out, but Catholics are predominant of the victims. But just on the IRA and its violence, do you think there's a sectarian edge to it? I don't think you can make the point that religion is central to Irish identity and to broader identities a hundred years ago. I don't think you can make that point and then pretend that there is no sectarian element to what happens in the Irish War of Independence. I am not for a minute saying it was a sectarian war and I wouldn't want that to be mischaracterized, but to imagine that there were not people in the IRA
我们将在下一集谈到。我们将谈到汤姆·巴里。汤姆·巴里，以及第二部分是停火后在班登河谷（Bandon Valley）发生的13名新教徒谋杀案。彼得·哈特绘制了所有这些事件的图表，他确实这样做了。我认为他在其中犯了错误——他确实在其中犯了错误，而且是重大而严重的错误，首先，他对采访的脚注
who were sectarian, who disliked Protestants intensely, who were excluded from land ownership or from positions of power and wealth, who had inherited a history in which their people and their religion had been stripped of the land as against other who won't. I think it is a denial of reality to imagine that there is no sectarian element in it. I think the question is, and it has to be posed on an individual basis, to what extent somebody was motivated by sectarianism or by other impulses in causing them both to join the IRA and then to kill. You'll notice in a lot of Irish ballots, it's all about dying for Ireland.
是不够的，这留下了把柄。我们可以将其归咎于历史学术研究的易错性，这是我们所有人都容易犯的。想象我们中的任何人能摆脱这一点是不正确的。然而，人们的感觉是，彼得·哈特使用采访的方式并不准确，而且他虚构了与死者的采访。现在，我认为这后来被证明并非如此，但这种争论仍在继续。
Nobody really wants to talk about killing for Ireland, but killing is massive in its impact on the lives, obviously, of the people who also do the killing. And it's an extremely difficult conversation for people to have. And Peter Hart, so I was on a train to Belfast. It's 20 years ago now, more or less, and I ended up talking to somebody across from me in the time when people used to talk to each other on trains before phones really got going. And I had this great chat with this Canadian bloke. And after about half an hour, really,
第二点是一个更重要的点。那就是他使用语言来描述西科克和班登河谷发生的事情时非常松散，以一种挑衅而非几乎的方式。在他写的一些东西中，他使用了关于种族清洗的语言等等。这非常符合巴尔干和卢旺达时期的特征。你能看出这是怎么发生的。这也是一个试图在某一领域崭露头角的历史学家的作品。
because I'm obviously not the greatest detective of all time, I realised it was Peter Hart. And we're going to a conference in Belfast, which I was talking at as well. And in the way of these things, he was a really, really nice fella. We went for pint on the way to the conference, which you did. Soften the blow. Belfast at lunchtime is most enjoyable. And we walk around the corner into the conference and there's people protesting about him outside. They've set up a table. They're handing out material against him and his book and his reading of history.
当你攻读博士学位并将其变成一本书时，你能看出你可能会被诱导过度使用语言。在我看来，他在某些事情上完全弄错了。他并没有完全收回，但他显著地收回了部分那种语言。我能——我的意思是，回到战争本身，我能以稍微不同的方式提出这个问题吗？那就是询问源自拿破仑时期的、将新教徒和天主教徒视为单一岛屿一部分的理想，这当然体现在三色旗中。绿色和橙色都在那里。在1920年，这个理想已经开始褪色了吗？
So they view the work as being a scurrilous assault on the legacy of the IRA, particularly in Cork. So what Peter Hart did was he wrote a study of the IRA in Cork during the War of Independence. And it's a brilliant book in large measure. It gives a study of social class. It gives a statistical basis around the violence and everything around really, really formidable original piece of scholarship. The two controversial parts of it, largely speaking, are a Kilmichael ambush, which was a major ambush run by a man called Tom Barry.
纵观19世纪，爱尔兰民族主义与天主教的结合是一个在那个世纪积聚势头的过程。丹尼尔·奥康奈尔（Daniel O'Connell）及其在1820年代及之后的运动为其注入了巨大的动力。天主教教会权力的认同、增长，以及他们与英国政府达成的关于教育和健康的交易——允许天主教会在其中扮演某种田园牧歌式的角色等等——在这一切中都至关重要。到1916年发生革命时，爱尔兰人身份与天主教的日益认同已经在顺利进行中。你可以在当时写的诗歌中看到这一点。
And we'll come to in the next step. We will come to Tom Barry. And so Tom Barry and the second part of it is the murders of 13 Protestants in the Bandon Valley after the truce. And Peter Hart charted all of those and he did so. I think the mistakes he made in them and he did make mistakes in them and they are significant and serious mistakes in that he his footnoting, first of all, of interviews
我们接下来会谈到。我们将谈到汤姆·巴里。因此，汤姆·巴里以及第二部分是停火后班顿山谷13名新教徒被谋杀的事件。彼得·哈特详细记录了所有这些，他确实做到了。我认为他在其中犯下的错误，他确实在其中犯了错误，而且是重大而严重的错误，首先在于他的脚注，即采访记录
was inadequate and that left the door open. And we can pass that off as the fallibility of historical scholarship, which we are all prone to. And to imagine that any of us escape from that is not right. The sense was that Peter Hart had kind of used interviews in a way, however, that were not accurate and that he had invented interviews with people who were dead. Now, I think that's subsequently been proven not to be the case, but that argument still continues.
是不充分的，这留下了话柄。我们可以把这当作历史学术的易错性，我们都容易犯这种错误。认为我们当中有谁能完全避免这一点是不对的。当时的看法是，彼得·哈特在某种程度上使用采访的方式并不准确，而且他伪造了与已故之人的采访记录。现在，我认为后来证明并非如此，但这种争论仍在继续。
The second point is a much more important point. And that is the point that he used the language to describe what happened in West Cork and in the Bandon Valley in a really loose way, in a way to be provocative, not almost. He used language around ethnic cleansing in some of the stuff that he wrote and so on and so forth. It was very much of the time of the Balkans and Rwanda. And you can see how this happened. And it is also the work of a historian who's trying to make his name in a field.
第二点是一个更重要的点。那就是他用一种非常松散的语言来描述西科克和班顿山谷发生的事情，这种语言带有挑衅性，甚至差不多就是那样。在他写的一些东西中，他使用了围绕“种族清洗”的语言等等。这非常符合巴尔干和卢旺达那段时期的特点。你能看出这是怎么发生的。这也是一个历史学家试图在某个领域崭露头角的著作。
And you can see it when you do a PhD and you turn it into a book that you can get lured into over into a use of language. And he got stuff entirely wrong, in my view. And he did not entirely, but he significantly walked back some of that language. Could I, I mean just going back to the war itself, could I frame the question in a slightly different way, which is to ask the ideal that dates from the Napoleonic period of Protestants and Catholics as part of a single island, which of course is expressed in the tricolor. The green and the orange are both there. Is that starting to fade over already in 1920?
当你攻读博士学位并将其写成书时，你能看到这一点，你可能会被诱导而过度使用某种语言。依我之见，他完全弄错了。而且他并没有完全收回，但很大程度上收回了其中一些言论。我能不能，我是说回到战争本身，我能不能换个稍微不同的方式来提出这个问题，那就是问一下，源自拿破仑时期的“新教徒和天主教徒作为一个单一岛屿的一部分”这一理想（这当然在三色旗中得到了表达，绿色和橙色都在其中），在1920年是否已经开始褪色了？
Through the 19th century, the identification of Irish nationalism with Catholicism was something that gathered momentum through that century. It was given a huge amount of momentum by Daniel O'Connell and his campaigns in the 1820s and onwards. The identification, the growth of power in the Catholic Church and the kind of deal of around education and health that they did with the British government to allow them a sort of a pastoral role and much more is vital in all of this. And the increasing identification of Irishness with Catholicism was well underway by the time there was a revolution in 1916. And you can see that in the poetry that was written
在整个19世纪，爱尔兰民族主义与天主教的融合在那个世纪逐渐积蓄了势头。丹尼尔·奥康奈尔及其在1820年代及之后的运动为其注入了巨大的势头。天主教权力的增长，以及他们与英国政府就教育和健康问题达成的一系列交易（允许他们发挥某种牧灵作用以及更多其他作用），在所有这一切中都至关重要。到1916年革命爆发时，爱尔兰身份认同与天主教的日益结合已经在大力推进，你可以在当时创作的诗歌中看到这一点
and in the beliefs of other things. But there is also a strand of republicanism which utterly rejects the Catholic Church and believes in secularism. And it is- And it's that stuff that's going to shade in this period. It is well into shade at that period as the nationalist movement expanded, particularly before 1919. Right. So just as we move towards the end of the episode, let's remind ourselves that we are in 1920.
以及对其他事物的信仰。但共和主义中也有一个流派，它彻底拒绝天主教并信仰世俗主义。正是这种思想将在这一时期留下痕迹。随着民族主义运动的扩展，特别是在1919年之前，这种痕迹在当时已经非常明显。没错。因此，在我们进入本集尾声之际，让我们提醒自己，我们现在处于1920年。
The British have been flailing around. They've got a divided command. They don't really have a clear strategy or clear instructions from London, where David Lloyd George is still leading this coalition, this wartime coalition that he has managed to perpetuate after the end of the war, which is reliant on the Tories in particular, and they of course are very close to the Ulster Unionists. So the British finally pass the Government of Ireland Act, and they hope this is going to somehow magically fix the whole issue.
英国人一直在盲目挣扎。他们的指挥权分化。他们并没有真正明确的战略，也没有来自伦敦的清晰指示。在大卫·劳埃德·乔治的领导下，这个战时联合政府在战争结束后设法延续了下来，它特别依赖托利党人，而他们当然与阿尔斯特统一派关系非常密切。因此，英国人最终通过了《爱尔兰政府法案》，他们希望这能以某种神奇的方式解决所有问题。
And the key thing here is that you're going to have two new home rule parliaments, one in Dublin and one in Belfast. And this is massively important because this is what effectively establishes Northern Ireland, which is going to be six counties, three of which, well, two and a half of which are overwhelmingly Catholic. So if you have six counties, Ulster was historically a nine county province, but the number of Catholics in the nine counties in the 1911 census was about 43%, which was a little bit close to the 50% rule which would have left things tricky for the future Northern Ireland.
这里的关键在于，你们将拥有两个新的地方自治议会，一个在都柏林，另一个在贝尔法斯特。这极其重要，因为正是这一点实际上确立了北爱尔兰的地位，它将由六个郡组成，其中有三个（嗯，有两个半）绝大多数是天主教徒。因此，如果你有六个郡——阿尔斯特历史上是一个九郡省，但在1911年的人口普查中，这九郡的天主教徒比例约为43%，这有点接近50%的规则，而这会给未来的北爱尔兰留下棘手的问题。
If you went with six counties, you had a 34% Catholic population, which was still seen as a big enough area to be viable. But there was enough of a majority, a Protestant majority on which to do it. So that was chosen. But what this meant, and this is the deep irony of all of this, is that the one thing that Ulster Unionism had been founded on initially was the rejection of the idea of home rule, any home rule. It wanted only to be ruled from London. And now they're left with the situation whereby they must take, as they see it,
如果你选择六个郡，天主教徒人口比例为34%，这在当时仍被认为是一个足够大且具可行性的区域。但它有足够多数的抗罗宗（新教）多数来完成这一目标。所以这就是选择。但这意味着——这也是这一切中最深刻的讽刺——阿尔斯特统一派最初赖以建立的基石之一，就是拒绝任何形式的地方自治。它只希望由伦敦统治。而现在他们面临这样一种情况：他们必须接受他们所认为的
their own parliament on a permanent basis to keep them out of an all Ireland 32 county home rule parliament. Right. But they gladly take this, gladly take it. And in the context of the situation. And you're left then on the other hand with a 26 county home rule plan. The Government of Ireland Act are reheating of the 1914 Government of Ireland Act, which is nowhere near enough for Sinn Féin. Right, so this is not going to fix it at all. I mean, it might fix it in the north,
他们自己的永久议会，以使他们免于加入全爱尔兰32郡的地方自治议会。没错，但他们欣然接受了，欣然接受了当前的局势。另一方面，你得到了一个26郡的地方自治计划。《爱尔兰政府法案》是1914年《爱尔兰政府法案》的重新加热，这对于新芬党来说远远不够。没错，所以这根本无法解决问题。我的意思是，它或许能在北方解决问题，
while leaving a massive Catholic minority, but in the remainder of Ireland, the Government of Ireland Act is kind of irrelevant? Oh, it's entirely irrelevant. Right. So we've reached the autumn of 1920. The conflict's been going on for almost two years. We began with a misty-eyed ballad, but there's a real edge to the story now. You've described the reprisals of the Black and Tans in the auxiliaries, houses being burned down, families being driven from their homes and so on. And now we're going to come to the 21st November, 1920, the most controversial day of the entire
同时留下一个庞大的天主教少数群体，但在爱尔兰的其他地方，《爱尔兰政府法案》基本上毫无关联？哦，它完全无关紧要。好吧，我们已经来到了1920年的秋天。冲突已经持续了将近两年。我们以一首带有一丝感伤的民谣开场，但这个故事现在有了真正的锋芒。你描述了黑黑卫队和辅助部队的报复行动，房屋被烧毁，家庭被赶出家园等等。现在我们将迎来1920年11月21日，这是整个冲突中
conflict, the game at Croke Park between the Dublin and Tipperary Gaelic football teams. And that day will go down in history as Bloody Sunday. And Tom, we will be moving now to Croke Park for the next part of the story. And can anybody, is there any way that people desperate to hear that episode with Paul, is there any way they can do that? Well Dominic, it will stun you, it will stun Paul, and it will stun all our listeners to learn that there is because members of the Rest is History Club can hear that episode right now by signing up to therestishistory.com. And that is a website that no one has ever heard before.
最具争议的一天，都柏林和蒂珀雷里盖尔式足球队在克罗克公园的比赛。那一天将作为血腥星期天载入史册。汤姆，我们接下来将前往克罗克公园继续讲述故事。那么有人，那些渴望听到保罗那一集的听众，有什么办法能听到吗？好吧，多米尼克，这会震惊你，会震惊保罗，也会震惊我们所有的听众，因为答案是有的，因为“历史其余部分”俱乐部的成员现在就可以通过登录 therestishistory.com 收听那一集。这是一个以前没人听说过的网站。
The rest is history.com. Go there and you can hear all about the most notorious episode in the entire history of the Irish Revolution. For everyone else, people who don't want to do that, we will be back on Monday and we will see you then. Bye bye. Thanks so much Paul. Bye bye.
therestishistory.com。去那里，你可以听到关于爱尔兰革命整个历史中最臭名昭著的一集的全部内容。对于其他人，也就是不想这么做的人，我们将在周一回归，我们到时候见。拜拜。非常感谢保罗。拜拜。
Goodbye. Hey everyone, here's that Jaws clip that we mentioned during the break. You can listen to the whole episode for free on the rest is entertainment dot com. There's no cast at this point as well. The cast is so last minute for this. It was nine days before principal photography was due to start. Two of the three main parts, Quentin Hooper, still hadn't been cast nine days before. So everyone's ready. Everyone's ready to go.
再见。大家好，这是我们在中场休息时提到的《大白鲨》片段。你可以在 the rest is entertainment dot com 上免费收听整集节目。而且这个时候还没有演员阵容。这阵容太临时了。离主要摄影开工还有九天。三个主要角色中的两个，昆汀·胡珀，在开工前九天甚至还没确定演员。所以大家都准备好了。大家都准备好出发了。
You know, the whole unit who are eventually played by Robert Shaw and Richard Rophers in the movie and those two have a massive feud there were so many other different people that they considered now Brody who was actually played by Roy Scheider it's a brilliant performance he's so sort of it's an amazing performance so put upon and like every man but yeah i mean the other people considered were Paul Newman, Charl Heston Robert Deval Gene Hatman like definitely the last two of those could have done it Yes, I think Charlton Heston was desperate to be in and Spielberg again. You know what? He was smart right from the beginning Spielberg Yeah, he said thing about Charlton Heston. He's too big a star. Why is he too big? Because you know Charlton Heston always wins That's the problem. You know Charlton Heston is gonna defeat the shark. You know what?
你知道，电影中最终由罗伊·施奈德和理查德·德莱福斯扮演的整个团队，他们俩之间有很大的矛盾，他们考虑过的其他演员还有那么多。现在，饰演布罗迪的罗伊·施奈德，他的表演非常精彩，是如此的棒，那种饱受压力又像个普通人的感觉。不过，是的，其他人选还包括保罗·纽曼、查尔顿·赫斯顿、罗伯特·杜瓦尔、吉恩·哈克曼——最后这两位绝对能演好。是的，我认为查尔顿·赫斯顿渴望参演，而斯皮尔伯格也是。你知道吗？他从一开始就很聪明，斯皮尔伯格。是的，他对查尔顿·赫斯顿有个评价：“他是个太大的明星了。”为什么他太大牌了？因为你知道查尔顿·赫斯顿总是会赢，这就是问题所在。你知道查尔顿·赫斯顿会击败鲨鱼。你知道吗？
What right sure it is gonna do you You don't know what Roy Scheider is going to do. You just don't know. So it's really important. Roy Scheider has the look of a man who could be eaten. He could definitely be eaten. You'll be like, yeah, I can see it. I don't know if his agent is going to be saying he's going to be in it, but he can't be eaten. He could definitely be eaten. Charlton Heston eats sharks. Charlton Heston eats sharks. Again, another great title for the book. Roy Scheider actually heard Steven Spielberg talking about it at a party and Steven Spielberg was saying he'd have this idea for how he Could get this shot the shark to jump onto a boat Which I thought I'd like to be in that movie. That sounds good
什么？没错，他会搞定的。你根本不知道罗伊·施奈德会怎么做。你就是不知道。所以这真的很重要。罗伊·施奈德有一种长得像会被吃掉的人的气质。他绝对会被吃掉。你会觉得，“是的，我看得出来。”我不知道他的经纪人会不会说他会参演，但他不能被吃掉？他绝对会被吃掉。查尔顿·赫斯顿吃鲨鱼。查尔顿·赫斯顿吃鲨鱼。又一个适合这本书的伟大书名。罗伊·施奈德其实是在一个派对上听到史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格谈论这个，斯皮尔伯格当时说他有一个想法，关于如何能拍到鲨鱼跳上船的镜头。我想，我挺想演那部电影的，听起来不错。
I like this kid and he said I would like to be in this movie anyway, I'm John Heston By the way, I'm bound never to work with Spielberg after that. Hi everybody, you're still here right at the end of the episode. I'm very impressed by your commitment but listen I have a question for you. I want to ask you something in confidence. Do you sometimes listen to the adverts on these episodes? And do you sometimes think, do you know what? I wish that the listeners to this podcast, I wish they were listening to an advert about my brand rather than the other stuff that Tom and Dominic are promoting on here. If you have thought that, there is of course only one way to find out what that would be
我喜欢这个小伙子，他说我想演这部电影。总之，我是约翰·赫斯顿。顺便说一句，我发誓在那之后绝不再与斯皮尔伯格合作。嗨，大家好，你们居然还在这一集的最后。我对你们的执着印象深刻！但听着，我有个问题想问你们。我想私下问你们一件事。你们有时会听这些单集里的广告吗？你们有时会想，你知道吗？我希望这个播客的听众听到的不是汤姆和多米尼克在宣传的其他东西，而是关于我品牌的广告。如果你这样想过，当然只有一个办法能知道那会是怎样的
like. You can disrupt the procession of adverts. You could be the next HSBC premiere or the many other tremendous companies that have advertised on the rest is history. And you could put your brand in front of millions of like-minded listeners by advertising on the rest is history and indeed the other shows on the Goalhanger Network. Now you may be thinking, I don't know what the Goalhanger Network is. Goalhanger are the company behind this very show. And if you are in the market to increase the value of your brand, Goalhanger would love to hear from you. You can register your interest or
体验。你可以打破广告的常规。你可以成为下一个匯豐卓越理财（HSBC Premier），或是曾在“历史其余部分”上做过广告的其他众多杰出公司之一。你可以通过在“历史其余部分”以及Goalhanger网络的其他节目上投放广告，将你的品牌展示给数百万志同道合的听众。现在你可能会想，我不知道Goalhanger网络是什么。Goalhanger正是制作这个节目的公司。如果你正打算提升你的品牌价值，Goalhanger会非常乐意听到你的声音。你可以登记你的兴趣，或者
indeed your company's interest by going to Goalhanger.com right now. And that is Goal, G-O-A-L, Hangar, H-A-N-G-E-R, dot com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
事实上是登记你公司的兴趣，现在就访问 Goalhanger.com。网址是 Goal（G-O-A-L），Hangar（H-A-N-G-E-R），点 com。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。